all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibantas ty got travis fresh
on that thursday evening destiny
campfire nice little special guest debut
that we're gonna get into but before we
do that let's talk with the cheetah
himself ibantes how are we doing sir
doing good still insanely hooked on the
elden ring literally don't want to play
anything else did get my raids in for
tuesday though got my insidious crafted
wow
you got that many um joys last week
last week i got two bought one this week
i ended up getting a couple i bought i
ended up with like six red outline ones
so it is crafty yeah
so it's been it's been rolling so the
insidious has crafted i haven't leveled
it up yet because i've still been
playing a lot of elderly but the
crafting is done
uh we got raids done
normal raid we're getting down uh
challenge this week
i'll save my thoughts on that one
no doubt but yeah not
not loving not loving the challenges so
far but we'll get to that a little bit
later when we kind of get to the destiny
chat um but yeah elden ring level 89 i
think i'm right around 60 hours i have
still so much more to do it's insane i
love this game so can't stop playing
travis
i'll save the good stuff for later
yeah um
yeah it's been super busy at ign doing a
bunch of stuff uh last week i did gdc
coverage so some of the the games that i
did previews for that weren't out yet or
now or hadn't been announced yet have
been announced so you can see some stuff
on ign.com i wrote um
and then yeah just ramping up for a
bunch of coverage coming down the line i
can't talk about most of it uh
exclusive drop that exclusion i am
weirdly doing a um
a raid guide for destiny for ign i guess
they want to try their hands at that so
they're having me to put together a
valve disciple right you do it assemble
do you do the simple call-outs please
tell me you're doing a simple call
oh see at some point i gotta put all
those together but i haven't got to it
either so yeah yeah so i'm doing that
this week actually it's supposed to be
due tomorrow for destin but uh we'll see
if we make that deadline
um but yeah uh doing doing a bunch of
content and you know grinding it out man
it's been a lot of fun i've been playing
a
little bit of tiny tina
finished elden ring on sunday which i
think i maxed out at 150 plus hours or
something in that game so it was crazy
and yeah it's been a so cool now i'm
really excited about weird west which
came out
yeah
today which uh
i've heard mixed stuff on that i'll be
curious tell what you say about that
well i had a chance to review it but i
have a uh a conflict because i'm pretty
good friends with the um the creative
lead
lucas
little flex right there little flick
he's a oh not not really
of the week
yeah it's been crazy man it's been
absolutely crazy
just recorded a crazy two good defining
dukes um one that just came out i mean
one that's going to come out and then
one that i had uh
chris ray gun and a certain cheetah from
the last word
we stuck them in for a full spoiler cast
and um yeah it was it was really good i
don't know when they when they're gonna
drop that how to see what's up calling
on that when they're gonna do that but
i'm excited for that man that was a fun
shot that was good i got to guess i got
to guess it was fun yeah it was funny
because he was like because basically
i'm full disclosure but trav
my plan is to get you on to like i'm
getting the fam i'm getting the hobies
on at some point so i just got to figure
out the pockets you know what i'm saying
i think for trav honestly where i want
you it's like a star wars thing or
something like that to really let you
shine and i'll let you go but it was i
was proud like i just let e go and i was
like look at what was it for what what
game which we did which queen which we
do
so we had chris ray gun we had uh
ibantis i don't know when it's going to
drop so i don't know when that's going
to happen but um it was a fun episode
and then me and maddie just recorded
something for duke that was fun and then
yeah man just been grinding brother just
a lot of stuff going on but enough about
that we got
a patient celebrity guest yes let's
bring him into the podcast
all right welcome my man so the last
word episode number 191
this week bungie struck back at the
world of the internet playstation is
changing their game a bit and more games
continue to get delayed the gaming
world is full of news and we have a
guest tonight who has his finger on the
pulse of the industry every day a gamer
before he could probably dress himself
and colecovision started his journey
long long ago this veteran gamer has
enjoyed tight action platformers
third-person emotional stories fun
adventures to tough challenges his
history is really full of variety when
it comes to games an east coast man who
sounds like he was born with a voice for
the airwaves and you'd swear he'd been
on tv and if not someday he probably
will be and honestly
it would be very cool to see him on tv
because he looks like he's just gonna be
that east coast guy
if you cross sports radio with a love
for gaming you will find this man
hosting the crossfire podcast always
surrounded by a hilarious mix of
personalities they will be talking about
the gaming news of the week with likely
a hot take from every angle due to the
diverse cast that he always has so let's
welcome a man who knows how knows how to
hustle as the restaurant business can
only teach and a warlock who fears fomo
more than anything else the one the only
mr mooch how you doing tonight sir buddy
what an intro man i gotta be honest with
you i didn't know if this was the last
word or mooch this is your life
that was fantastic
it bought this i found another quality
card for you too listen this is an
outstanding thing uh you know there's
there's a lot of podcasts i've been on
but and and cognito knows this i've been
on ilp you guys know about crossfire
right
but this show but
ibontus runs a hell of a ship and let me
just tell you guys what i'm talking
about he handed me a homework assignment
listen i got a pen with a cheetah on it
and he said you go sit in that corner
and when you're done filling it out i'll
let you know when you come on the show
this was phenomenal unbelievably
organized i love it incognito you know
shame on me for not having travis and
ibottas on the show yet they will be on
crossfire very soon but i want to say
this much you know cognito you've been
on crossfire enough times i always do a
dignified type of uh schedule i do
topics i send them out ahead of time i
try to give everybody the intro so they
know how to go in i thought i had it
down
i thought i had it down but if i ever do
get to do late night tv like i told my
guidance counselor years ago okay
ibottas is gonna be my guy he's gonna be
my guy so i wanna say honestly thank you
to everybody shout out to fork boy shout
out to uh the great lord addict that's
here as well uh
you know and and just so you guys know i
heard cognino say he's going to get
travis
and he's going to get ibontis on his
show uh uh defining duke but what he
doesn't realize is this okay there's one
thing that i got that these guys don't
got access to a lot of pizza
nobody turns the pizza guy down at the
door if i walk in behind travis i got
three pies i'm on the show it's all
right that's what you got to do
this is how you solidify your position
how do we just gotta say
new york pizza is superior to chicago
pizza and it's a go new york pizza is
superior to chicago pizza and you could
stamp it and you could put it on a shirt
i don't care that's the truth sorry
absolutely but i want to say thanks to
everybody for having me on this show uh
looking forward to the topics uh and
just you know and you guys know i love i
do love destiny but i did let the uh the
panel know that i haven't played witch
queen yet
uh because of the great things that
travis was just saying i've been playing
a lot of horizon forbidden west and
playing a lot of elden ring and also
been playing tai natina's wonderland
which i wish they named it something
else but the game is still fantastic
the game is really a lot of fun right
yeah about this don't give me that
that's not my fault i don't know man i'm
not playing at you i'm laughing at chat
right now
oh okay uh
super chats real quick i'm gotta go
forte first is are my eyes deceiving me
is that
is that mooch look at this handsome
devil looking forward to all the yelling
on the show tonight absolutely don't
hate on destiny and then we got tp
hayden here with the five dollar super
chat does ibontis have some advanced
fuji with the earth sauce tonight i hate
that that is actually like that didn't
make it a week and we're back with the
earth got that going right
by the way is
water for anyone who's wondering what
the hell they're talking about somehow
this happened last time the last time um
i have my pickiness when it comes to
eating and all of a sudden
thanks thank travis for earth sauce and
then thank nope for keeping it going
because
i think it was maybe an hour later on
twitter i was i was already being
crucified so yeah yeah
thanks guys for the super chats and fork
boy he didn't say can't stay long still
in surgery absolutely shout out to him
for that 10 super chat keep up the great
content and mooch so
yes look man good to have much in the
building long overdue appreciate it
being a destiny fan play a little bit
with them but um before we get into that
obviously you know some new people at
the camp i've never heard of the mooch
you know what's going on so real quickly
i know we had coleco talk just a brief
overview you know what i'm saying from
the game perspective from an og
perspective
you know what i'm saying what kind of
excited you into gaming first
it's it's funny because you got to
attribute it to the family right so the
family was kind of into it everybody
kind of dug it so in all honesty
my pops he loved it right dad loved that
he did he game no but he was very
accepting of it you know i mean he
really kind of got into it he had no
problem with uh the family kind of
enjoying that extracurricular
extracurricular activity pardon my my my
wording but like to be honest with you
i put colecovision to sound ancient
right i put that down there to sound
ancient but really i'm an nes guy and i
know that we hear a lot of people are
really hardcore sega and that's fine i
think sega in all honesty i had a second
generation as well later on
sega it's good to have balance
don't you shake your head damn it
listen
i i admit that was my fanboy cog days
and yeah i i i gotta get over that
i was like it was it was
time if i blew a recovery if i blinked
wrong he's gonna punch me through the
through the discord chat i'm like i'm
like sega what's boom
he's right because
look all full nes was the wave every it
was it really was it really was it to be
a sega kid at the time was was tough so
i i still i still have those bruises i
still have the but this is your story no
no no please by the way chime in
whenever you guys want but i got to tell
you the reason that i say this though do
you know what really sold it think about
it for a second i don't care if you were
playing atari i don't care if you're
playing coleco i don't care how old you
want to go back in your retro years
the minute you saw
the gold cartridge right that's it
that's what i'm gonna say yeah it's over
people said this is what the next
generation is and it was and i just was
a nintendo guy all the way through my
youth right
so really got into it that way but to be
honest with you it's it's just man i
think it's it's the best pastime and
here i am at this age now i'm still
enjoying it to this day and this is the
thing and i'm sure everyone that's
listening now or becoming a parent later
okay
enjoying video games with the family has
been an outstanding experience and to
bring gaming into the household and to
be uh it doesn't matter we played it
takes two together right split screen i
mean i'm just trying to think of some of
the games you know people gave it a lot
of crap but bug snacks i don't care
we're talking about this i'm trying to
bring it all the way from nes to today
right so realistically it's just an
amazing amazing pastime that uh i truly
believe that and i'll give credit where
credits do jeff keely for example right
jeff keeley went and did his thing with
the vgas
and i truly believe that this industry
needs that recognition i truly believe
that it we need that recognition right
because it went from talking about
gaming like quietly to your body at work
i welcome them i say come on in that's
fine the more the merrier but
at the same time it was tough when we
were younger because people weren't it
wasn't the the cool thing to do
um so you know it's it's hard to really
say how i besides the fact the family to
say i got into it that was the main
reason but i never stopped i never
stopped and you know when you go to uh
with those halo tournaments in college
right you got that then you got
everything from we made drinking games
out of mario kart
okay i don't care what you're talking
about it happened
so uh just a lot a lot of good memories
there man and and i'm glad that the
community exists that exists today a i'm
glad that podcasts exist i'm not saying
that because i'm just on this one right
i'm glad they exist to spread the word
and i'm hoping that a younger generation
picks up where we leave off cog and uh
about to see travis like i hope that
they pick up where we leave off
and keep this this this industry alive
and rolling because you know like i said
and i'm sure we'll talk about it a
little bit tonight the industry's
changing okay the industry is changing
and i'm not gonna say that one is better
than the other
but i will say that we have two main
companies in microsoft in in playstation
right our xbox and playstation both
making games
but both taking a different avenue
towards success not one i think they can
co-exist personally
but i'm interested to hear what the rest
of the panel has to do and when we get
to that by the way and nintendo's
walking around the party with a dunce
cap on at the time but that's fine
they always do what they want to do
you know no believe me it's like they
make good like kirby came out and like
people love the game
but then you see with some of the stuff
they do with copyright takedown on like
a 1994 super mario guide and weird it's
just they always and it took them four
years to turn on bluetooth audio on the
switch
you love him and you hate him at the
same time it's just nintendo they always
like they put out a game you're like
this is going to be a hell of a lot of
fun and it's also going to be generally
very polished like metroid dread i loved
that game yeah absolutely so good loved
that game that was
like that grew like climbed my list
really fast until i beat it right before
the end of the year on a holiday trip
but man then when
when they finally were like hey yeah we
turned it on i was like we turned on
with what firmware update
it took you four years to give me
bluetooth audio now i can just go big
and that's all it took i was i was
almost beside myself but no i mean
gaming is
like travis might be the youngest one
here but we've all been around for a
while and played way more games than we
should and again i started on nes i
remember like my parents got it and then
they rented like just golf no anybody's
just just golf just nes golf how that
thing looked i spent you know 10 12
hours when i was a kid playing mario 3
and my parents were wondering if i was
okay all those types of things very very
cool but no like gaming is one of those
hobbies
i'm hoping as developers grow up with us
which a lot of them are you're kind of
seeing the change in the themes of some
games and that nature
that
gaming continues they make old people
games because when i get old dark souls
might be a little bit harder but
hopefully they have like old man dark
souls so i can still play it
uh shout out real quick to gk bells uh
you guys are the bomb sending love thank
you for that 20 super chat by the way as
well so a lot of love coming in chat
tonight thank you guys very much um but
it has been interesting i want to start
with destiny but we got some interesting
variety topics and we got a ban of
variety on the show so we'll probably
hit those in the second half but we got
some interesting ones but first wanted
to see how much destiny you guys have
been playing this week i know i can see
sometimes you guys are playing destiny
sometimes you're playing on other stuff
with discord but what have you guys been
uh cog travis mooch
we'll be we'll be asking questions here
for you too uh listen if you don't mind
about this while everybody's giving
their destiny takes and i said this to
travis before the show i said hope you
don't mind i'm going to play the role of
the reporter and be asking you guys some
questions because i have not been there
for the last exten expansion or two and
that's shame on me but i'm very
interested to hear and maybe if you guys
don't mind while you're describing i
don't know if any i'm sure your audience
is well versed in destiny but someone
like myself i'm interested to know
someone who has missed basically you
know starting from last time you played
it was before uh what was the expansion
before uh last um
shadow keep i played but there was the
other one beyond life
so beyond light i i purchased it i have
it on all systems right i i don't have
it on pc but i did buy it i have it on
playstation xbox
and um
played probably about uh three quarters
of what you should to get through the
expansions campaign edition but again
drop the ball and that's that's
completely my fault and honestly i miss
it not a big deal i'm very no but i'm
very interested to hear
exactly exactly so i'm very interested
to hear what you guys have to say and
what you guys have been enjoying in the
witch queen no doubt travis set it off
man yeah um i have been playing some
destiny um not a ton just because pvp is
a little i don't know if you guys have
been in the trial world but it's
rough charles has not been in its
greatest state recently yeah um but uh
yeah i i do i've been doing the raid
every week and that sort of thing but
there's also just a ton of games i've
been behind on so i just got over my
almost life-ruining addiction to elden
ring because i beat it so
now that that's in the rear view i'm
kind of i'm open able to to play a
little bit a little bit more diversity
in my my catalog but um yeah i've still
been logging on destiny i kind of like
that there's not a mandatory you know
ritual to do every week where i've got
to run and do all these uh
i can't remember what they were called
the um
the uh seasonal activity whatever that
thing was called oh the sciops did ups
battlegrounds yeah battlegrounds yeah
totally uh remember that was
anyway um it was a nice little story but
i'm kind of i'm kind of glad that uh
we're taking a little break and they're
probably working on some more content
because um yeah
redoing the same activity every week for
nine weeks is a little much for me i
think four was was the right right
length four or five weeks or whatever
they were doing so no doubt no doubt
yeah i've been rocking still been
rocking um you know i did all my psyop
stuff i've been kind of actually working
on crafting now um i've been working on
some real good roles as far as i
remember what i told y'all like was it a
week ago that i found the pulse that i'm
just like wrecking people with in like
pvp and it was peace of mind apparently
the role that i had is the god roll and
now everybody's trying to get it and
trying to craft it so
that was fun you know messing around
with that i've been kind of doing the um
campaign stuff just over just to kind of
get my alloys up and materials and mats
and stuff like that you know i have been
playing a lot of pvp i did um shout out
to
tv he was like he saw me playing charlie
like what are you doing he's like you're
still playing tv this is gonna be uh
quoted and we're also after five minutes
on a youtube video so currently gaming4t
says pvp is ass bro yeah that's what he
said because i said bro i need i need
the scout and then they had a god roll
on linear they had to raise regret which
i realized i couldn't get after the fact
but that's another story because i
didn't prestige
let's not miss quote gaming forte i
believe he said pvp is a money which
is
you know it's it's been
what you've missed now from which queen
you owe yourself to do witch queen
because yes this is
prime
campaign at its finest everything we've
always wanted they they it went from
that was a decent story for destiny
like you know it's a live service
destination for destroying your destiny
right that little right
in the rest of the gaming world they'd
be like nah that that's not it that
that's okay that you got something but
no this is this is the cohesive
narrative this is like this like this is
no i mean we you and i just literally
spent about an hour and 40 minutes on
defining dude ultimate please but guys
if you want to check that episode out
hit that five dollars get you that early
access for what they drop but also gets
access to the ultimate sacred symbols
plus
um but we spent now in 40 minutes
talking about it me chris you all of us
were at this point where this campaign
is not as you said hey it's a pretty
good one for destiny it's like no this
is one of the better first-person
shooter campaigns i've played period
yeah it is like
so do you guys recommend this as a solo
play is this a solo play oh yeah yeah
absolutely yes yes okay and they
actually set up the missions to scale as
a solo player or as a trio so it's that
speaks a lot to what you're saying
because i did feel with beyond light
that uh i did start playing it solo and
i just enjoyed
the amount that i did play with friends
because i thought that the story kind of
was
it wasn't capturing me it didn't bring
me in and i've heard by the way i i do
know that you guys speak the truth
because everybody said what you guys
said about witch queen that this was the
defining expansion piece and would you
go as far as to even say to gamers who
haven't played destiny this is the time
to enter if you if you have not yet from
the campaign story this is the greatest
that that is there's like that's the
case
from that campaign standpoint it is the
greatest story they have told from
destiny period now to travis and
ivanka's point there's still other
aspects of the game that are suffering
right but as far as that campaign yes
the way it led into the raid and then
everything else that goes happens after
the fact and sabbath doing as a villain
it's just and what they set up
the lore
i don't want to spoil but the lore is
going in a place
that it is such a payoff from everything
that you've already known because you've
been there from the beginning
so you know the basics of it and to see
what they do with it and it's just so
excellently put together like this is a
meaty game and a meaty campaign for sure
i was like i played it solo on stream
took me about 12 hours now i did on
legend difficulty but it was about 12
hours to go through experience at all
probably little breaks but i mean yeah
you're talking a 10-hour campaign for
destiny that is
it's not like anything it's ever been
before it is a very different level of
campaign for them as we said the
surrounding basic playlists and you know
certain things
but still it's one of those that if
especially if you've already got it yeah
you it is it is worth your time to boot
this up and experience it and you can do
it solo on normal you can do it so low
on higher difficulty whatever you're
comfortable with it is worth the journey
can you explain to me why still and
please tell me it's changed cognito why
has the warlock had the worst
looking drab clothing
in the history of destiny we fresh now
i hope so okay so
you have an exotic ornament that is one
of the best in the entire game so
let me tell you something you know you
guys introduced me as the salesman but
these guys are selling me on this i'm
about to buy it before the end of the
show let's go hey it's on sale right now
now's a good time
is it real look at this
this is
aka cheetah yeah no i think that that's
this is you know in all honesty that's
the one thing so shout out travis you
know this right fashion souls that's one
of the things in eldon ring i've been
playing a lot of that as well
and uh you know sometimes you choose the
less powerful equipment so you look
better right
and uh that's that's me that's me in a
nutshell with destiny so
that actually that actually isn't a
thing anymore in destiny either because
they added trans transmog
and still have the stats you want yeah
so you can you can make any of your
armor look like any of the other armor
you own uh so you can you can you no
longer have to choose style or
those bungee guys man they are they are
listen they might have took them some
time but they are listening are they not
they are listening to people
yeah
shout out to bungie damn why i think
that's why destiny has survived a lot as
long as it has in part is because it
hasn't always delivered as a game in
fact i would argue that most of its life
it hasn't really delivered its its
promise to players but they're very
communicative they probably have one of
the better um you know community
management
groups and organizations in the games
industry i think honestly that's what
sets them apart they're built for a game
as a service because they have that that
core kind of support uh
culture oh yeah oh yeah shout out real
quick to mr joanna dark
hello gentlemen first time listener
hello to lord cog as someone who hasn't
played destiny since iron banner now
iron banner is an event for pvp that
happens often are you talking about like
i think he means of iron correct which
would be
one year three is it worth jumping into
the game at this point the campaign is
excellent we've touched on some of the
surrounding pieces of
seasonal stories and also the state of
pvp and gambit and strikes and stuff
there are some very good things in
destiny there are still some things that
definitely need some work the campaign
alone is worth the experience for 40
bucks the season pass that is one you
could
wait on and maybe get later on itself if
it's up to you and you want to if you do
the deluxe i feel like you're going to
be in for you want to play it for pve
that's the right place to play it for
them right now to play if you're going
to play pve you're in a great spot of
the world of pve pvp gambit
these will love and we'll see in a few
seasons it might but no that's that's
one of those for sure that right now
it's a great campaign experience and
that pvp pve stuff is in a great spot
yeah yes sir i sort of i've sort of um
obviously i reviewed it so what can i
say that i haven't really written 3 000
words about but um i i sort of think it
depends on what you're trying to get out
of it right if to you destiny's always
been a personal adventure um
then
the campaign is is without it it's
without the caveat of for destiny right
oh that's pretty good for destiny
you you could just play the game without
knowing anything about destiny lauren be
like it was a good story which that's
the first time first time it's ever
happened in a destiny game for sure um
and but if you're if you're
if your hope is to have a lot of end
game uh with with as a solo player
don't play it like uh
yeah yeah yeah hard gated or behind
people that are in groups uh if your
goal is to play pvp
don't play it just stick to halo
infinite it's free
i think the the problem with um with
with pvp in destiny is that it's just
been sort of left to rot on the vine
it's it's got a great sandbox great uh
game mechanics but they haven't added a
mode or a map to it in so so long
probably since you last played honestly
um
so it's been a it's it's been a
rough rough for us pvp mains but um it's
still a fantastic game and it's the best
date it's ever been just sort of depends
on what you're trying to get out of it
destiny has a lot to offer and if you're
looking for the thing that it's doing
really well right now
what you're gonna like mooch is um
beside like first of all as
excellent weapons and armor that they've
added this season it's been so much fun
to play with but what you're going to
appreciate is you're a vet so you're
coming from d1 you come from
the
being able to customize your character
and really get down to the
nitty-gritties and you're going to like
void 3.0 you're going to look like being
able to pick the grenade you want the
the type of
rift you want the super the aspects
you're going to have this synergy that
you can like okay finally what they
started with stasis they're now going to
do to each subclass and void was the
focus for which queen and then they've
already announced next season the
subsequent season is going to be arc
everything's getting a rework perfect so
that you have the options you know
you're not locked in because you know
how destiny 2 started you kind of locked
into these triangles yes you can only do
these moves in this thing that's over
we're getting now a little a little mini
mmo a little bitty customization and
synergy thank you for bringing that up
cognito and in all honesty that was one
of the things that i'm not going to sit
here just because you said it so that
was my biggest problem that was one of
the issues i felt with destiny 2 when it
kicked off uh shout out to the great
gaming forte in the chat he says let
more yelling less
right this is the quietest i've been um
let me just because i got your volume
down a bit so we balance everybody i was
just gonna say that's it that's the
greatest by the way forte don't blame me
where are you guys now it doesn't matter
right everything that like we said the
boys over at uh uh the boys and gals
over at uh uh what is it there bungie
have been listening where are you guys
playing though what where what what what
platform
it doesn't matter because it cross-plays
maybe it doesn't matter but i mean i'm
gonna go ahead and say listen by the way
the great ibontas can't hide okay he
can't hide the second i turn my computer
on he lets the world know it pops up in
the bottom right corner ibontis is
playing destiny too so he's playing on
pc yeah uh but now cog i will i will i
be safe to assume the series x or are
you pc series x36 only because the clan
was over there they got mad when i left
it right they got mad because d2 started
it was eastfall he got he built out this
awesome computer so i could you know
really take content creation seriously
what is it almost two years ago
so since then i experienced the joy that
was during the xbox one era so
absolutely that was the joys of me
getting more than 60 frames and i'm like
oh
screw that i'm standing here hey i'm
sitting over here so the clay was mad
they were bad because i left them for
frames you know say it but then i said
look when the series series x comes out
because ninety percent of the clan is
there and they're going to get 60 and
they're going to get the the main thing
was that
and frames right now
please and they get to get the fov and
i'm like all right 60 and then the 120
with the pvp so yeah series x is where
i've been the clan is very happy but the
cool thing is like you know you will
have guests on you know last word and
they're on playstation and shout out to
um what's her name
living legend off forget her name last
lady legends last lady legend she helped
you know trav was there too we they got
us through the group do the uh what's
called the rock the vowel disciple raid
yeah they were on playstation we did
game chat it was so cool so it's just it
really doesn't matter now like the only
time that matters
is don't play with teddy when he on pc
and you're on console because you're
going to play all the sweaty people on
pc because if you the minute pc and
console merge on pvp they throw you into
the pc pool okay and that's what i'm
like oh god they're killers here
that's good to know though yeah so pve i
think you mean cheaters yeah don't cross
the streams that's basically don't cross
the streams yeah you said it travis
trav were you playing uh i play on xbox
mostly um okay but yeah i i own it on
everything so it kind of depends who i'm
playing with you know if i play with the
i play with d flawless a lot and he's on
playstation so i'll i'll play it on
playlist you'll go over okay yeah yeah i
i i own it everywhere so it kind of just
depends like to cock's point you can
play everywhere but it's not always a
fun experience especially if you're
playing with the
pc people because they always want to be
in discord and not use any of the
actually good you know chat programs
involved and so it it becomes a uh it
becomes a a a problem i think right he
bought us his eyebrows told the story
face told me everything told me
everything
call me old school but i don't think i
should have to open up a you know second
third fourth application to get my my
chat i like it to just be you know kind
of part of the experience you know i
love it i love how discord's free
yeah
oh lord here we go well you know they
should have you know you bring that up
and i know this will bring a smile to
ibotta's face but you know we're waiting
here on the console side i don't care
which side you are why don't we have
discord as an app available right now i
mean there are workarounds right now on
the uh on the xbox i can't remember what
it's called there is a program you can
download something or something i can't
remember the name of it off top of my
head but uh
twitch
yeah shameless uh shameless plug here
but when i'm on twitch uh my right thank
you very much uh my warzone buddy uh
james uh james vincent he he he uses
whatever that is i can't remember what
it's called uh it'll come to me in a
moment but nonetheless it's a discord it
works because he's in through my discord
and that's how we're able to stream and
play warzone together on there but my
point being is that uh i you know you
guys are just selling this i mean i
don't even know
cognito you're gonna definitely guy bro
like this isn't for you
and through so that's why i'm ashamed of
myself for not
not playing it you've been playing some
excellent games you just now have
another one waiting for you when you
finish
and i told you about this i was like you
bought this march 31st no problem i'll
be i'll be there i'm going to be there
with
lights on and i'm going to be playing
witch queen and he goes that's not you
have plenty of time she's like relax
plenty of time what happens march 31st
comes i'm probably going to buy it
tonight i'm going to have to show you
guys receipts of the purchase no like
the actual receipt not the twitter
receipts
you guys are going to want to see the
actual receipt so if you can make sure
your credit card numbers on that receipt
that'd be great
well you know i'll do my best
i'll give you one that expires tomorrow
okay fair enough yeah
make sure to send the receipt to bungie
so they know they're doing yes
all right well speaking of
bungie
uh i did want to touch on this last week
obviously
content creators were scared
had some issues with the world of
copyright strikes and everything on
youtube yeah this week over the course
of the weekend and all of the stuff that
went down we figured out most of i think
basically all that stuff should be
reversed at this point copyright strikes
removed they got their stuff fixed they
also fired back
bungie has filed a lawsuit against the
bad actor against every one of the
basically
i mean false claims or you know claiming
to be them
false claims of copyright strikes i
think there were over 40 150 000
per
strike so if this is say like one person
you're talking millions of dollars that
somebody is theoretically facing in a
legal lawsuit from bungie but they also
kind of called out youtube
which
they calling them out and having sony
not quite officially there but close
this is finally the point youtube is
really bad about this somebody if they
can you know get around youtube if they
can you know fudge their credentials
basically they went to youtube and said
hey your security this system kind of
sucks in a much more detailed way but it
is something that somebody if if
somebody is die hard enough they can
work their way on there around the
system of youtube and strike enough
people
so
it is yeah it's like if there's eight to
ten possible people or however many 150
thousand dollars for anybody's gonna be
bad if you spread that over multiple
people either way however many people
that were doing those things that's just
going to be a really bad thing but the
fact that bungie is getting youtube
process involved is something that
needed done
long ago because it is a very we talked
about it last week it's an old
antiquated process with copyright
strikes and other things you can have
five seconds of fair use of something
and get flagged for it or whatever it
may be so
the risk of a content creator to have
their channel potentially gone in three
strikes completely deleted and somebody
with you know multiple hundreds of
thousands of subs could you know
asda cross was
you know nearly 500 000 subs if there
would have been another strike and you
know say bungie wasn't batting for them
at that point
they could have lost their entire
channel in a weekend
and then a week later nothing
and that's just that guy hit yeah biff
got hit he got his reversed
um and some of the people at the
soundtracks bungie kind of gave the lay
of the land of how to handle those
things in the future to get the
licensing get approval for stuff that's
not officially able to be out there but
this just kind of showed the the holes
that youtube's process has right now and
i'm glad to see somebody as big as
bungie with the backing with the power
that they have is
hopefully going to get youtube to wake
up now will processes happen
quickly
no because everything at youtube is
probably going to take a little while
and there's a bit of a mess but
hopefully this gets the ball rolling on
the process
so i was just kind of curious to you
guys thoughts on this whole
bungee you know firing back with a
lawsuit against the bad actors and then
also kind of calling out google i was
just curious your guys thoughts on
basically this big turn of events
yeah i mean i'll jump off like yeah it
was it was really surprising because to
be honest we haven't seen like google
and youtube kind of have their feet put
to the fire in a long time most of us
all hear content creators on some level
or have a channel or you know do a show
on a channel and you know it's
frustrating because you know these guys
we're getting strikes
like you get a strike this is not all
you know a little monetization flag here
and there a strike three of those and
you're out your channel's gone so you
know to have these content creators have
this happen to them and you know what's
funny when you're gonna laugh like the
thing about this
way google always envisioned them you
old enough you about your energy
generation they always remind me of like
there's no customer service there's no
no direct person you could speak to so
it's like the old remember the old
inspector gadget cartoon where the boss
you don't see you just see the hand and
the cat just the hands
that's youtube to me there's no there's
no figure right it's just this evil
entity that you you can't contact and
they got control of everything you don't
say they just struggle with the cat with
the dog
you know it's funny because you nailed
it though cognito and it's funny that
ibanta said that he's happy to see
bungie fire back we need the bungees of
the world i don't mean just bungee in
this case but anybody big to be able to
get that kind of attention because
actually cog you saw also was going on
in the community even outside of destiny
people are just getting and that's
you know listen a lot of people put
their their hard work and their time
into into these channels of theirs right
there's nothing worse than getting that
email you know so i mean you know what
you guys know what i'm talking about and
so
the whole point of the matter is that i
i'm glad that we have the bungies in the
world and other companies i hope stand
proud next to them when this kind of
stuff happens to say that that's not
that's not going to be acceptable
because let's be honest here everybody
on this show and everybody listening to
this show
we all promote these games and do a lot
of the work for these companies for them
and yeah you may get a couple of pennies
here and there but nowhere near the
money they're getting from what we're
doing oh they don't cut so they're
getting their cut so let's be honest you
know what i mean like this is a
tremendous amount of advertising when it
comes to video game industry and it's
that's why i think it's real important
to see what bungie did that's why that's
a stand-up company right there uh now i
bought this do you think that did they
react as quick as you wanted to see them
i don't know if they could do it much
faster i agree i just i was wondering
no honest like the fact that i saw when
the strikes went down first two weekends
ago on saturday i think is asked across
like somewhere in the middle of the day
or maybe sunday cosmo community manager
replying on a sunday at like 8 30 in the
morning central time dude was up early
saw it they were applying um the new
community manager lyanna she was
replying saying hey we can't say
everything things are being investigated
we have something going on monday for a
meeting i mean they were on it on a
weekend i can't ask for much more than
they were trying to do you really can't
things can't happen theoretically on a
sunday because typically an off day for
a lot of people but they made things
happen pretty fast i mean monday things
were coming back so i mean i'm
not impressed yeah i was like um it's
probably i don't know how fast it could
have been but i was like i can't picture
it being much faster than what happened
was everybody resolved in the same speed
of course like asda crossing the big
ones and biff were probably handled
first maybe they're smaller ones if they
got hit that could have been a little
slower but either way
um i think they handled it as quick as
they could and i'm glad to see that they
called out everything that they did i i
do think that we need to see something
uh cognito and what you're representing
but you're right we have to have
something like an 800 number i don't
care what it is even if it's uh you know
they don't get back to us for weeks
that's fine but right now like you say
there's a time and a place and we feel
like we have absolutely no power no
control no reach we have no reach
and uh that's something i think that
does need to change over at google i
hope that they do something like that in
the future but
with so many people having channels i i
don't know how they would even from
their side of it it would be an
interesting logistics nightmare to see
how you would handle every single
complaint but nonetheless they have to
have something you have to put something
in place
travis any thoughts
yeah i mean i i kind of have the least
uh horse in this race i think you're
muted i think cognito you're beautiful
sorry sorry yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but it looked like a funny joke
just based on your smirk no just like i
was saying like for the smaller guys you
know it's tough because it's like you
know you don't have you know that that
outlet to get you know the information
too but yeah i'll give it to you i was
over here with you i'm very curious to
see what you got to say yeah i was just
going to say i i kind of have the least
horse on this race just because i don't
really use youtube as a platform except
for through you guys and
uh i guess bitcast also posts their
video to youtube but i don't really have
the same relationship with it as you do
but
i was i was talking earlier in the show
about how i think destiny has survived
as long as it has mostly due to its
community management and i think this is
a great example of it because if it was
a any other game you know and and they
had this problem and it took a like a
substantial amount of time for them to
fix it uh think about how that would
have impacted the game i mean oh yeah
the the content creators feel burned and
maybe move on or just straight up can't
post any new content and then the people
who follow them and play the game
because of it you know lose lose
interest are so pissed off that they
don't come back and that's how you kill
a game man like that's one of the ways
you can do it so i think they treated it
with the urgency it needed and uh yeah i
mean i think
of all the things that destiny fans have
been really pissed off about over the
seven years they've been playing destiny
community management has almost never
been the thing that they're upset about
and i just think that's like that's
their ace in the hole as they just
they're really on top of that stuff yeah
so
yeah i'm glad to see they've done also i
just think our laws are super outdated
when it comes to
average money that's
we talked about that last week as a as a
pre-law
guy who likes reading uh reading um
legal documents so uh yeah
no no need to retread that but yeah
we're we're super outdated yep yeah for
you bro
yeah so i was like i mean it was just
nice to see them kind of come out
swinging so it's a good way to start the
week and then tuesday got a new weekly
reset we are at that point we got a
couple months uh basically until the
season ends but we had season of the
risen story basically pan out
um i ranted about legend psiops
battlegrounds last week which still has
no purpose in my mind um but this week
you got you got to get that insight doc
i mean you can get a half of it from the
normal mode yeah that's still anyway um
i don't get them started no but this
week again booted up on tuesday got the
group together and we hit two out of the
three raids and what group is this a
don't floss over this a-list celebrity
group you'll be raided we've talked
about this you know who it is
mention the bourgeois bourgeoisie i want
you to name it
it was literally through twitter
messages like five minutes later i had a
group of crazy creators i was like
well i did a podcast with you yeah i was
like i was like all right
somebody was talking to destiny for a
minute i gotta ask a question there's
something that he said that stumped me
right there he said two out of the three
raids
yes there's three raids available right
i ran no two two two three characters
three is kind of thank you guys okay my
apologies they never do that i mean
there's one raid right now available
correct well there's multiple raids
there's only one that's worth like
powerful gear like leveling up here
you do the past rates but i'm saying
like yes yes but i mean there's one new
rate i'm not sure you even know about
the content vault but you can't do all
of the old raids oh yeah oh you hold the
glasses
you can no longer play like the forsaken
campaign yeah you can't play the og you
can't play a couple of the first two
campaigns
okay
so they have that's all right i mean
kind of those i played until i was yeah
i mean i'm good there but i mean even
leviathan i played that one yeah to
death
so
i'm looking forward to this new one
what's the power level that you got to
get to to even hang out with you fellas
in the room
yeah when you log in you start at 13.50
as everyone does they bump the floor up
to 13.50 for everybody for which queen
and then now power cap is
15.50
for 1500
is basically like just by doing anything
1550 is the powerful gap from all the
powerful engrams and then pinnacles 10
more the nice thing about the campaign
if you do the campaign on legendary
difficulty they give you eight pieces of
gear and eight upgrade modules to that
are at 15 20. so it takes that okay 50
power level gap it makes it only 30 that
you got to do honestly one of the best
quality of life things they did is take
that chunk out of leveling so if you can
play through each mission on legendary
it's worth it yes that's what we do yep
okay
that's good advice appreciate it just
jumping on legendary when you when you
get in yeah sure okay
it honestly makes everything feel a
little more
it puts weight to each of the missions
they may be a little more difficult but
then missions feel how they should i
think how they won't steal them um but
no so two weeks in a row we've done the
raids at reset and so far we've done two
of the challenges
i'm going to be completely honest i
don't like these challenges
what we predicted would be a trap
predicted last week the mechanics uh the
conditions for these challenges to put
you in the carriage situation this week
is this one was just a little tedious
it's exactly it was tedious it was just
you could only hold one symbol on
caretaker you could only hold one symbol
at a time so instead of running and
picking up three you would run into pick
up one get out run yeah the two people
just keep switching
one you come
and the weird thing about it is that if
you
because you have to do nine
you and you're going you're going in and
out so quickly
you kind of you kind of have to wait
around sometimes because you might still
have stacks of darkness
on you before you enter the second time
and you're just sort of like
all right so basically the name of the
game is you have to just stall the
caretaker
even longer than normal right and that
has you have to be successful at that
and you also have to do ad control
because uh if the ads are allowed yeah
that's right yeah
yep yep yeah so it's like this is a lot
about this writing the guide last week
was
keeping the champion alive until you can
all kill it at the same
um time you just have to kill the three
champions at the same time but you one
spawns when you kill the glyph keeper
right well somebody's gotta get that
second compass go through figure out the
symbols okay next one's up okay now you
got two of them roaming around
and then the same thing once all three
are running around then you can go okay
stun him kill him
but it's just the fact that hey here's
this game where you want to shoot stuff
and keep things dead as fast as possible
so you don't die no we're gonna make you
not kill stuff on the first one and then
same thing as the triumph challenges
don't kill guys too soon so i don't love
either of those and then this week
it's
instead of going in and being efficient
picking up three that you're allowed to
do now you gotta do one
so so far like i don't know what the
exhibition part's gonna be with all the
relics if it's gonna be each person can
only hold the relic one time or
something it's gonna be chaos then you
gotta figure out who's gonna rotate when
and where because we have a pretty good
rotation now because the last two rooms
you can actually clear
with the same two of us holding the
shield and the taken relic the same and
we just wait and repeat the same people
they're just
i don't like
something that makes you play worse is
the best way i can phrase it
and i don't it's just bad yeah it's like
i don't i don't know who looked at these
and was like that that's a cool mechanic
it's not a mechanic it's just don't
shoot stuff or do it in a worse way and
i'm just not a fan of these challenges
so far i don't know what next week is
going to be i don't know what rook is
going to be but
i really enjoy the raid but i can tell
you these challenges
i'm not a fan i'm just wanting to say
that right the raid's gonna question can
i ask what the reward for said
challenges are i mean it is the second
chest so if you're going for crafting
two chests oh yeah that's double chest
on that encounter
so i mean so far it hasn't been that bad
on normal
but i can picture on master just making
everything take long the master on
the first encounter
keeping an unstoppable champion alive if
you get that unstoppable champion first
on master
yeah oh
man that person get terrorized exactly
they're just gonna get absolutely yeah
just chased by this nightmare creature
yeah keep stun locking them that's all
you can do what's the commitment on time
guys when it comes to something where
you guys are all already at max power
there's no doubt about it now you guys
are just keeping up you're trying to get
those chests you're trying to get that
loot trying to keep up with the
challenges
what is the commitment for somebody like
yourself once you're at that level
to withhold where you are and keep up
with the community week to week i'm
asking it on a week-to-week basis so
that's actually easier now because
keeping up isn't really a factor um
they they sort of squeezed that out now
you you you can
uh play every week and i but i think now
the grind is more about finding the
perfect weapons and perfect armor yeah
that sort of stuff and it's sort of it's
all an optional grind you don't have to
play to be relevant like you like i
would argue you used to have to do that
you'd be running around absolutely
grinding spin foil until uh spin metal
until the cows came home uh that was
just like a requirement but uh yeah not
anymore mm-hmm
okay i appreciate that
yeah it's
i mean a lot of people you could play
for the first four weeks of the season
you could take two months off
yeah and then when the next season comes
out it's only a 10 power level grind of
the next season anyway so it's pretty
minor so if you're close in the first
place cool yeah it's honestly a lot
easier for
i don't want to say a casual but you can
jump in for a month of the first season
destiny then you got a couple tuesdays
and then
take two months if you want to do that
there's really nothing stopping you
cognito how about the campaign now the
campaign for which queen how long did
that take to complete because this one
wasn't more this was a much more
fulfilling one than past ones right so
let's say oh by far yeah right i mean i
i'll defer the trap because he reviewed
it how long what was it what was the
gameplay hour so that's the beauty of
this one is um it's sort of a choose
your own adventure in terms of how much
of a commitment you want it to be
because if you want you could just play
the campaign like you always have on the
standard difficulty and you could
probably blow through it in
five six hours at the most probably it's
kind of kind of a kind of a usual run
but
if you want to be [ __ ] cool
absolutely exactly
yeah
i like that
on that too
if you want to be dope uh you can um you
can play it on the become legend
difficulty which i highly recommend i
highly recommend that that adds a whole
bunch of like raid mechanics and
additional difficulty
um and that will take you like
that can take you a while i i like know
i like know life did it and i got
through it on the first day but like if
you're not no lifeing it you haven't
played destiny for a while you're not
running like the best gear it'll
probably take you a couple days of like
i'll just say it was like
maybe 15 hours yeah it was 12 hours
straight for me sounds right
and i yeah it was about 12 hours say 12
to 15 if you space it out get through a
mission maybe try but there's like
there's some checkpoints in there and
stuff like that right checkpoints now
yeah so that's not particular so that
that particular mode that travis was
just speaking of though is that do you
have in order to get the gear he's
discussing and to get the perks do you
have to play that solo
or can you play that through with the
buddy yeah where you play with the buddy
and it scales to the difficulty and then
the best part is if you beat the entire
campaign in that mode you get a gear
that basically jumps you [ __ ]
so ahead of you
forte i hope you got nothing playing
after the show
shout out to forte uh yeah yeah he's i i
gotta get this man you guys i've never
been so excited to spend 20 something
dollars in my life it's 40.
pardon me that's what well that's why i
bought this i was hoping for an about
this coupon um yeah sorry it'll be 37
after coupon okay
yeah the thing what you're gonna like is
like again the the each level so to
speak is lengthy like you you're gonna
play what would be considered like a
destiny strike and be like completely
like okay that's good and that's part of
the first level yeah right and then
what's cool is they reward you by doing
a legend by giving you double chests
yeah and an upgrade module so you can
upgrade and keep going and i think it
really helps people who are just trying
to power level so they reward you for it
and you you'll you'll be increasing
slowly but to like what ian travis
saying that the scaling is really done
because the challenge is in such a sweet
spot
and the thing you're going to like also
is that because of obviously i'm not
going to spoil it but you you do know
that obviously the hive got the light
okay so no the the mechanic of the
lucent hive
changes the game
okay because you're gonna face the foe
that you're like wow i am not used to
this this is
not only having to deal with their power
but how you have to take them out and
crush the goal sometimes you got to put
yourself a precarious position because
just by finishing them is not enough you
have to go to their ghost and kill their
ghost and that changes the whole
complexity of the game and it's so much
fun man
i'm telling you this is for you like all
you yeah so like a guy and a guy in chat
i'm in literally that random guy in the
comments thank you for that name that's
hilarious
he just said he's like he took his time
with the legendary campaign took him
about four days and he just really
savored it and i think that's the way
it's like you do
like i know life done on the first day
because i had a lot of crap to do but
yeah i would say like savor it play a
couple missions a night something like
that enjoy them take them in but do it
on legendary so it feels weighty and
stuff like that and
you'll enjoy this campaign more than any
other destiny campaign no questions
asked
now when is the uh when is the next
season break when is that next day may
24th i think
okay so plenty of time to get in right
now and enjoy the enjoy the game for
what it is and shout out to that random
guy in the comments too he's actually
makes a good point no he makes a great
great name by the way but uh outstanding
point there because like you know you
get into it
i'm not gonna be able to know life but
like travis said there's no way right
now with the schedule i have coming up
like cog was saying before the show hope
he doesn't mind me saying i had the same
thing today was just a long day right
today was a long long day brother so
i've got a lot of that coming up but
this is a game that i would kind of like
to eat away at you know what i mean and
get back into the community and play it
that's the way you play it bro yeah you
know there's something about it and it's
funny because i sit here and i'm
thinking i'm on my show but i'm on i'm
on a destiny podcast you know and you
guys know this but hearing this this is
the refreshing aspect when it comes to
destiny this is why i love destiny so
much
and i left it just because you know i
started playing other games about to set
it himself you could play for a couple
of weeks right put it down maybe not
come back for a month the problem was i
was doing that and keeping up with it
religiously the problem was that i got
to a certain point started playing a
couple of games
and it took me away from it for more
than that month two months and then i
felt like i was out of the loop i know
that they brought you up at the power
level we all knew that we knew that yeah
yeah but the the one thing i will say
that's still a bit of a struggle with
beyond light
and i think uh cognito i know you might
know him you know not do you know
noximus you remember knox yeah i don't
know he's he's big he's big he's big
into the destiny world himself and and
he he said you know almost want to join
me we'll we'll run through uh beyond
like and he did but there was so many
things when it comes down to your
inventory and the way you attach things
and the level up system things have
changed since i left like hardcore right
so that's the one thing when you when
you grab a good friend of yours and a
buddy and you're like come on in you
know
all i ever say to anybody which by the
way i'm talking to you forte because i'm
coming to you first forte you gotta
actually go we gotta go through
everything because there's so much to it
not just the lore but there's so much
that's going on in in your inventory
your items things that you guys have
picked up over the past two expansions
that i have not that i've got to be
honest with you like honest to god
that's the part that i think is
frustrating for friends when you have a
new person like myself coming back into
the mix i mean you guys can admit that
right you guys have had a mooch in your
life that was like you know listen right
you guys have all had a mooch your life
beyond destiny but nonetheless my point
is right they come in and they're like
yo cognito you mind running through this
with me and you're like absolutely
that's not a problem then they're asking
you questions and stuff you're talking
about set yourself back 45 minutes of
help session
so yeah that's the one thing that i ask
anybody that's going to be gaming with
me just take a little bit of patience
but because i want to learn the the
aspects of the game that i missed i'm
hearing the bonus i read what he does on
twitter i see his videos and the point
of the matter is you have to be caught
up to speed on all that in order to
enjoy that lore of what you guys are are
really grasping right now mm-hmm yeah
try he's about to jump in yeah i was
just gonna say um that is the one part
of destiny that probably hasn't improved
yep and maybe maybe is even worse is
that if you're out of the loop for a
while getting back into the loop um i
mean you could you can play the story
without being in the loop really
absolutely just focus on the story and
and use whatever trash guns you come
upon it doesn't really matter um but
once you start to
approach the end game and you are
looking at all these materials and these
hundreds of currencies that destiny has
and tried to add dozens more um and uh
all that stuff then you start to then
you start to go oh boy this is
this is gonna hurt to like figure this
all out and weapon crafting was added to
the game which was crafted in the end
both super cool and super
uh scary if you if you're intimidated at
first yeah
yeah it's just it's got that typical
destiny like barrier of entry like they
want you to get out an excel spreadsheet
and like get into the destiny subreddit
and like you know get your abacus out
and all this crap and it's just it's
that is like the worst part of destiny
by far especially yeah and travis thank
you for a returning player i really
appreciate you agreeing with me on that
because um you know because i don't i
got to be honest when you're talking to
the destiny community i don't know if
they necessarily feel that same way if
somebody's coming back in because
they're
saying that it's well yeah but you know
what that we all are and i i love that
you know that's that's the part i feel
like i've missed out so you saying that
is it's a refreshing uh point to be uh
taken from your side of the coin versus
mine so it's nice to hear that and i
apologize to anybody in advance what's
the game before he says i know mooch uh
don't leave me at the altar like brap i
won't leave you like brap did i won't do
that i'll be there for you forte if
you'll be there i appreciate it but uh
no back to what travis was saying i
i do appreciate him recognizing that
because there is a large part of lore if
you haven't played a few expansions to
get back into it so
uh but i'll tell you it this this is
this is refreshing to know that this is
the time to jump back in and the great
ibantis just sent me a link oh yeah let
me know and remind me that it's on sale
you know on sale is one of the favorite
words in the mooch community
that's correct yeah i mean
that is the much way right
well the much way is hey mooch here's a
code but nonetheless that's a little
different that's a little that's a
little different uh but then this is
second best de montes and i appreciate
like those are powers i don't have so
that's fair
oh everybody's got them you got them
buddy
no cognito cognito listen if you're from
new york you already
it you know baby when i walked out of
the house that's how he started the day
you know
come home you'd be like how did you get
that bag don't worry about it don't
worry about what you worry about i
enjoyed it though right
shout out
no yeah it's like that kind of
covers most of what we had in destiny
but also we had gdc recently and there
was one specific slide that came out
about destiny there were a couple for
like graphs and retention and stuff like
that i don't want to go into too much of
those
um
just mostly because you could probably
break those down any way you want to but
we actually get to see the idea of
how long when seasons and expansions are
developed how long kind of the
development process is what is being
concurrently developed because
if you take the launch of beyond light
which launched with season of the hunt
and they like have the little tip of the
arrow from the slide that's where they
launch while that is launched you have
season of the splicer in the works
season to chosen already been in the
works for a while and then they just
start on season lost so literally right
when the season starts
three other seasons are in process and
already before season before beyond
light even starts witch queen's already
in development so we're seeing this like
concurrent development cycle of how many
teams are doing things at the same time
and obviously you have pre-production
and you have different pieces to all
this but we get to see a little more in
the future
so we got to see
that lightfall obviously launched or
launches
i'm guessing it's in 2023 we know that
one but i'm gonna guess it's farther
into 2023 than february because i doubt
we're doing that one again
um but we also get to see you got
multiple seasons there then we get to
see that final shape will get started
probably sometime later this year
because that's going to be
theoretically the final one but we also
got to see something nobody really
expected and i don't know if this is
just a piece
of like marketing spin or somebody had
fun with the slide but theoretically
around the type when final shape starts
development late 2022 and that is the
thing that is going to launch in 2024
probably
they're also going to start developing
some other large arrow that is
redacted and this could theoretically be
what falls after the light and dark saga
which is supposed to end in final shape
so they're going to be working on
theoretically two different pieces of
destiny large pieces of destiny at the
same time along with the seasonal
content as they go and i was just
curious
if you guys had any thoughts of just
like hey is this a time scale that's
just squished down do you think there's
a reason why this
redacted arrow is nearly the same like
concurrent development as final shape i
was just curious what you guys think of
this because it does look like it shows
that we've got four seasons with
lightfall four like multiple seats well
one two three
that's going to be between one two three
i can't tell how many seasons are with
final
shape
that's the big question i have
too many
is the answer
but i was curious you guys thoughts on
this one because i'm sure you both saw
it
yeah i'm putting it somewhere which
could check it out if you didn't see it
but um yep it's interesting you know the
development cycle what they got going on
is that another expansion
you know
is that the rumored
was it matter you know that's another
thing i don't know if that if if this is
exclusively the destiny i'm not sure the
context but um yeah the development
cycle was i'm not i'm to be honest i'm
not too surprised with this because like
you said you know they they develop
multiple things at once right the way we
consume
we only see the the first product you
know the in-game product and then you
know you hear rumors of you know life
and so on and so forth but they they
think outside the box they're always a
couple of steps ahead
to me i was actually more concerned
about the other slide and that's the one
that had like the um the active user the
metrics i was trying to find that tweet
and i just couldn't yeah that's the one
yeah i put it in our internal discord
because
that's the one
shout out to teddy if he's listed and
travis would know what i'm talking about
as well you two you'll be
hours of engagement numbers yes i always
felt
it was always this innate feeling that
destiny knows
when i return like if i go away from it
i always felt like you ever come back to
destiny moochie like man i'm getting
good rolls and wow i got this exotic and
i've been you've got this like stored up
luck
or something back
get that man back at all costs right
shot yeah don't match the two corporate
cards talking corporate cog knows that
there is some algorithm that they like
yeah whoosh i've been playing so let's
give them all that good stuff give me
the good stuff you're back in
and it was interesting that they had a
metric that was like average weekly
return rate so they want to know when
you come back they want to know much i
said oh much you just bought the
expansion oh he logged in here's that xp
is that exciting
that's it
it's like when um you know your ex knows
that she's gonna see you so she wears
something nice no she's got that outfit
that's for sure oh she got that we got
the pizza on deck for boots i'm telling
you right
it's a goal [ __ ] yes yes i also i also
thought it was interesting that they
track uh positive versus negative player
sentiment yeah yes
what's that about they had vocal
i feel like i represent like at least
two percent of that leader you want to
enjoy it
based on my vitriol like it's i'm i'm on
the chart i'm like an outlier for sure
oh you are definitely going to charge
yeah for sure it's no doubt you're on a
truck
but uh but yeah that uh
i i think we all knew that this is how
they looked at the game and and are
equal parts um
happy that they're keeping track of the
game so closely and annoyed that they
seem to care so much about engagement
because uh they're they're to to mooch's
point
the reason that it felt like you could
fall behind so quickly is because they
were trying to get you log on every damn
week and trying to make it meaningful
like if you didn't you were gonna miss
something and there was a big fomo
aspect to destiny and i think that they
learned that that does help in the short
term but in the long term it really
hurts you because it means that your new
players are going to go down it means
that eventually the mooches of the world
are going to fall off of the the wagon
and they have a really hard time getting
back on because the fomo is is real and
and
once you once you just let something go
i don't know if you guys have ever had
this i obviously none of us have had it
with destiny but i've had it with other
games as a service where i was playing
every week and i was trying to keep up
and eventually i fell off the wagon and
then a couple weeks later you feel like
this relief off your chest like okay
yeah i i don't have to worry about that
it's behind me i'm free of it and like
that is that is a really so true
cathartic feeling
so true let that thing out of your life
i feel like
it's like it yeah dude like with i i had
that with gentian impact actually where
like i was really really into that game
but i just couldn't take it with all of
the other stuff i was doing at the time
and then i missed one week and it felt
bad but then the second week when it
kind of sunk in i i felt like this
relief of like traffic i don't have to
worry about it
it's so true because when you do break
away
and he knows this as well and now booch
is going through it don't you realize
how productive you are as a gamer don't
you realize like how many yeah since i
started
since i started variety streams like my
list of games completed is
just skyrocket like so much more
yeah and and that's why i'm very happy
with
the breaks that they're building in and
now they're even longer because these
tighter seasonal stories allows you to
see truly take a break
that was that was it cognito you nailed
that right there and when i did leave
that's the games i completed the games i
was actually even not only just finished
the game but the 100 them because now i
felt like i felt like i had a full
another 24 hours of sand in the
hourglass you know what i mean it felt
like that much more time opened up and i
remember i can't i don't remember who i
talked to somebody that everybody in the
panel knows somebody that we all podcast
with and someone said mooch if you've
left the game
destiny's referring to for this long
and he didn't mean this in any wrong way
so don't you know
he said you walked away he said just be
done with it because he said to be
honest with you he said he said be done
with it because he goes you have
you're playing all these games you're
talking about all this stuff on the show
i see you doing this and that on twitch
he's like i'm telling you once you get
back into it i'm not saying it's gonna
you're not gonna do any of it but it's
gonna drop
the the cool thing what you'll like is
the way it's designed now yeah this is
i've come full circle he'll say he would
be proud of me because i used to fight
eo in this back of the day and i wanted
to live in the game i want that's all i
want to do i love it so much it's home
right the gun play the music the
everything right that's why we love this
damn game right absolutely it's like
it's one of those things the way it's
constructed now with the seasonal model
it's like tune in next week and you'll
find the answer to this and then at some
point it's done
and even though the season is is still
continuing for the casual guy that's
just gonna take his time to get there
the hardcore will be done and you will
be done in a reasonable
short rate
and that's when you can step away
they've designed it now in a way they
want you to step away they're not
forcing the hardcore to necessarily live
in it and that's why i have more healthy
balance with it what they've learned and
i'm hearing this from rebonses i'm
hearing this from cognito and travis is
they've learned what the expression
means of absence makes the heart grow
fonder right so they actually do want
you in an essence
a little bit right
i think what i think their goal isn't to
you know the the meme of dead game you
know sometimes sometimes yeah dead game
a little bit i mean that that but not
not the games can live second lives in
this era of of you know no man's
sky-like rebirths and i think destiny
has had you know one of those every year
because it just it keeps building on
itself but i think what they've done is
they've they found the people like the
former cogs and said look you want to
live in the game we'll give you a path
to do so that is 100 good point good
point and then the people who don't want
to do it they can leave without missing
anything and i find myself sort of
sort of dipping my toes in either side
of that equation i get fomo about the
games i miss when i play too much
destiny right yes travis same get to
play and uh so i i there's sometimes
like right now i'm kind of going through
one where you know i reviewed witch
queen so it was my entire life for like
a month and now i'm sort of just a
little colder on it and i'm enjoying
other stuff
and then i have periods where i just
want to live in it and the great thing
about the game right now is that it
gives you stuff to do if you want to if
you choose it yes that's a good one okay
you're right okay and that's an
important aspect that i think again your
community knows this your community
knows this that's something that i
didn't know as well because [ __ ] you
made a good point a moment ago you said
you finished what you finished the
hardcore then step off right but if
you're enjoying what you're enjoying i
felt back in the day that when you got
everything that you had
that it was time there was nothing left
to do right there was legitimately
nothing left to do this you want to do a
raid on a saturday night right right
and then god forbid you have one or two
people who didn't run the raid with you
my god you're pulling your hair out so
yeah for sure which by the way that's me
nonetheless that's all right i make it
entertaining i promise but the point of
matter is but travis says that that is
another kind of hook that you're talking
about right now cog to get me back into
it because when you do accomplish
everything that's out there to get i do
want to have a reason to play the game
right you know what what they've done
and and e will speak to it is like now
they'll they'll give little what i
consider milestone things on the
calendar for the hardcore to do so like
hey two weeks grand masters are coming
you know right right right ease dismay
grand master psyops came it wasn't what
the you know juice wasn't worth the
squeeze in that sense but they are
giving little bits of content on the
road map for the hardcore still to chase
but again to travis's point it's
optional you know what i'm saying and
then to the casual point they'll say
okay you know what is the juice worth
the squeeze what am i getting at so i'm
in that middle part there's some things
i'm like oh no that's worth it i'll go
grind for that you know what i'm saying
and then sometimes i believe what i'll
ask you what's my favorite question so
what's the reward
tonight yeah i'm like tonight when you
get that hardcore thing
what was the word you were like double
rate drops in the chest for something
tedious i'm like i just don't
don't love that but it's like this
legend psyops it's not match made for
absolutely nothing besides a little bit
of insight for your seasonal challenges
that can go in the bushes for the ilp
yes
yeah that's that can go in there
earlier tonight he bought this and you
said no there's two chests and then then
cognito's like all right then i'll sign
on tonight right now the mooches are
about me
oh it gave it's a gun that gave me plus
one handling and i'm like no i'm not
doing it like i'm good yeah
you know i mean it doesn't matter if
we're talking about like wonderland
which travis says he he reviewed or
we're talking about something like this
i need to have that the reason i want to
get i want to complete this strikes get
the chest right in destiny the reason i
literally open every damn chest in
wonderland is because i don't know what
loot i'm going to be able to get right
i'm doing every side mission because i
don't know what's going to drop these
types of looter shooters are the reason
and like i said you know you talk about
this on the air and when you're doing
ilp i'm doing crossfire you know when
you're talking about a plethora of
different games you'll get certain
people to agree and certain people not
to this audience gets it i mean this
audience loves that so that's fine but
like that's the reason that i love what
i love i love the fact in these games is
you never know what you're gonna get
that's the fact that keeps people coming
back and i think honestly it's the
simplest it's the simplest uh slogan for
destiny but i think at the end of the
day it's what keeps people coming back
whether it's the fashion part of it okay
um and then let's not forget the like
you said the amazing gun play in level
design right along with music i mean
it's just it's it's it's hard to top it
it's hard to top this absolutely
absolutely
but you gotta eat yeah no i mean couple
other things they had on the metrics
report card they had vocal sentiment we
talked about that one rating last week
obviously they're not going to give your
actuals in your forecast for anything
average dau which i'm not entirely sure
what that stands for but you got new
players uh average weekly return weight
rate active users daily active users
so then you got new players 12 up say
that's over random week this is probably
for something recent maybe uh average
weekly return rate so you can see how
often to come back week over week and
then average weekly win back
i don't know if travis you know this one
specifically this one's not entirely
clear this could be like is this like a
mooch or like hey you want a player back
go ahead and play is this a lapse player
coming back or something that's exactly
what it is lapse players
so you got gross revenue up expansion
revenue up micro transaction revenue a
little bit down mm-hmm shout out to tess
and then
average arp of the david
average daily average user what is arp
that's gonna gotta be like average spend
or something like that of a daily
average user or something like that
um
arp
average average revenue per daily
average user or something like that
they got the dollar sign over here yeah
and that's and say those two are both
down as well
how much did he hit the atm today
and again like expansion's up like 24
microtransactions are down we don't know
when this is exactly from but the idea
is they track all this stuff they know
microtransactions how much they get for
expansions how many how often players
are playing now they could have more
stuff that they're not showing of like
how long people are playing like how
many hours they play and that type of
stuff we don't see and you know they
know that stuff too
but again the fact that we're seeing
some of this stuff and bungie showed it
was thought it was weird a little weird
little interesting a little bit of both
personally so just to see a little bit
behind the curtain of
what they are watching and if you're
wondering do they want you logging in
every week one damn hundred percent they
do of course because that's how this
little model goes but as we said
um
we're at the point where last season it
was that eight or nine week season and
then dragging on to finally finish
things out but then on the other side
now we get a four week story
um
and you get a little tighter experience
and you get a little bit of a longer
break and i think that's where we're
actually seeing
a positive change for their
tune in net for next week's episode the
seasons of tv just got a little bit
shorter and tighter but we still got a
very good story could i have used like a
week or two more on this one
maybe but on the other side like i think
it was a well-told story didn't need to
be longer and then now you get a little
chance to breathe as you guys are saying
the breathing from the game is what's
going to help us enjoy so that's the fun
part i agree with that i really do yeah
absolutely i think they found their
little pocket that works
and as much as sometimes we are that
small percentage of the hardcore it says
we want more we want more content
they've got the metrics to back up and
this model is working for them so and
now with sony's backing you know that's
going to be huge for them for the future
long term i know travis is concerned
about the movies and stuff like that but
uh you know we'll see we'll see yeah we
won't know i'm not sure i'm concerned
about the whole acquisition actually
yeah i know i like i like i like
dig
uh but for the swab we'll cover the main
point of the twab um
we do want to touch on are you guys
monsters or mechs i got to know
max i had to go max bro
monsters look good but
bro that's i mean if anybody has ever
heard of the word gundam yeah this is
gundam straight up the titan is gundam
the hunter is cave basically you know
what i'm saying i like the the wall i
look like something out of fantasy stuff
i don't know what it looked fire like
yeah
just look like if you're a titan man you
can't be on the monster team because the
cyclops looks so lame compared to the
dope transformer yeah you literally are
gundam yeah you're you're you're the
like the titans got the coolest out so
wait a minute and i hate to interrupt
this because but i i was gonna have
absolutely no idea what you guys are
talking about but i'm going to tell you
something check it out it's sparking my
interest yeah so it's sparkling
the past two years bungie's done this
thing where they have a um they have a
community vote to see which armor set
they're going to be adding to the game
okay and uh it's for their halloween
event so they're always really over the
top costume that halloween event is
classic yeah so last year it was
dinosaurs versus uh movie monsters like
a swamp thing and cyclops and stuff and
uh dinosaurs won pretty handily i think
they said 80 plus percent
voted for that one and this year the
monsters are back and they're going up
again i'm seeing it mex and so well just
based on those um
those concept arts what where do you
think you're at mooch as a warrior i
mean i'm looking at them right now i
mean i gotta be honest with you so i'm
looking
and i'm seeing so there's three sets
there's the mex versus monsters evolved
is it the mexer on the top no the
monsters are on the top of the top
so i mean and you guys got to help me
here a bit because like i'm not i'm not
used to the warlock ever getting any
kind of praise or anything anything at
all that's worthy of wearing from my
days back in the day i'm definitely
leaning towards the uh
i know you're not gonna lie i don't
think you guys are gonna like my answer
but i think i think
i'm going on the monsters man marshall
warlock is
the monster like is that swamp thing no
i'm with you on this move you don't know
i know a creature from the black lives
matter or something warlock looks better
than the person back warlock 100
i just feel that as a set
the mech set for titan i know all you
care about is warlock so i do that's all
i care about i respect
from a purely warlock perspective i
cannot dispute what you just said no it
looks good man yeah the monster looks
good for the warlock but for the rest of
the classes i mean damn that titan is
just that's just a slam dunk win like
they just like
yeah like that is it is and then you get
to play the hunter is kade the hunter is
kate it's kate it is yes
let's stop fooling ourselves right yeah
so yeah that will be so make sure
basically that your emails
links you're in a bungee profile emails
are set up
so you get the alerts and then april 7th
through april 13th the polls will open
and you'll probably only get the poll if
you have your emails linked up so make
sure you get those if you want to vote
so set those things up and if you vote
all you gotta do is vote whichever way
you vote you will get an emblem not a
bad looking emblem by the way not two
not too bad on that one
but the big thing in the twab
i wanted to talk about this because
travis
we have been waiting for anything
related to crucible anything related to
cop
classics
no no no like i think
it's gonna be a while but i think this
is this is the fact that it's actually
gonna be mentioned more than anything
survival is the name of the game when it
comes to our competitive crucible
playlists we offer powerful rewards
sadly not pinnacle to our players who
take on the challenge each season as
they reach the power cap for those who
wish to display their crucible mastery
we offer the unbroken seal and title
the unbroken seal and title is not going
to be available in season 19. so you
have season 16 season 18 17 and 18 to
get to legend each season to get that
now that's something if you want to do
that more power to you but in season 19
they are going to be changing things up
for season 19 release now season 19 is
the one that's right before lightfall so
this is
nine months away probably it's gonna be
a little while
they're taking a pass on glory and how
players engage with it in the crucible
what playlists offer glory how do
players earn it what does become legend
look like we can't answer any of these
questions just yet but we wanted to
plant a flag for the future as for our
updates for glory the unbroken seal
title basically you just need to get
that now because you won't be able to if
you don't get wow what's happening to it
what's happening to the seal
the seal's gonna go away
because if you don't get legend this
season if you don't start your work
towards legend this season and say you
wait till next season you won't have
enough time to get it three times so
that's they're giving you a warning now
to work start working on it so that's
all they're doing
sorry to interrupt just for clarity they
were moving a hardcore
uh goal that was in the game i'm just is
that what is that what's happening no
you're trying to push something that's
not there
now you're just trying to poke a beast
that i'm not even getting to right now
all i'm saying is they are going to
rework the glory playlist in season 19.
yes it is nine months away but it does
seem like the competitive playlist has
potential to get reworked now i have no
idea what that means is this gonna be
anything the crucible players that have
come through the podcast that travis has
asked for a ranked system is it gonna be
anything like that i'm not gonna have my
hopes very high but i wanted to get
travis's thoughts when he read this the
fact that they are going to rework how
glory works
in season 19. do you have any hope for
this travis
i do actually i think cog's
characterization of this is the exact
opposite of what he's thinking it is so
shocking
the uh the
on the unbroken seal has meant nothing
for a really long time because they made
it super easy to get like even people
who aren't really pvp mains or tryhards
could get it because the freelance
playlist and there's a bunch of ways to
just get it right so
i don't think it really meant anything
and we've all agreed that the
competitive playlist is not really it
doesn't achieve its goal of really
challenging the competitive it doesn't
have a ranking system or anything like
that so with that in mind i don't think
there's really a whole lot worse than
what we could we currently have
and if they're reworking it i'm willing
to hear them out i mean they can't just
keep doing the same thing they're doing
now right and so any changes any change
is good change for me i'm just happy to
hear that they know that it's a problem
and uh to ease point like we don't know
what it's gonna look like yet but
why be pessimistic when you don't know
the facts yet i say we know the facts as
they stand which is that competitive is
in a not great state and that so far as
we
knew up until yesterday uh
they they were planning on just keeping
the train rolling in the same direction
i think that uh the fact that they're
saying hey let's let's re-look at this
and change the way it is that should be
that should be uh comforting and
exciting to anybody who cares about the
pvp sandbox and destiny so
i'm not at all skeptical about this i
think uh i think
like i said
we're it's it's it's bad now so what fun
could possibly we're just gonna get
defeated what what are we risking by
changing things i mean just just do it i
was gonna say [ __ ] fix your face
like i was waiting for this
i'm trying to start trouble
when there's nothing to start i was like
what do you know what it is it's more
fun so i'm just curious because like you
know from the hardcore perspective and
shout out to forte who was actually it
was in the chat and i know i think and
he agrees with travis no i i'm not i'm
not trying to i'm just asking questions
i'm just asking so you are trying to
start a fire you piece up i'm just
asking questions my question is like
because from my understanding you
correct me if i'm wrong this is a title
that you you live in the competitive
playlist right you play to you have to
play multiple seasons right to gain this
so i was just curious for the hardcore
that now it see it appears that they
will be taking away the multiple season
grind aspect because i know some people
feel that this is a don't say
prestigious obviously it's not the same
as going flawless right but there were a
lot of people that at one time when
competitive was was the thing right that
they wore that um broken i was just
curious that if the hardcore felt you
know any way that they may potentially
remove the multi-season aspect of it
before travis goes we just got done
talking about them giving the ability
for people to step away play when they
want to and have the option of doing
that type of thing and this is leading
more into that now can you go hard now
granted i don't expect them to do ranked
if they do i will be
a thousand percent surprised but i
really don't expect them to i would love
it honestly i would just rather have my
expectations low and see it then be like
hey let me see a ranked playlist and be
like hey we got a little tweak like i
would rather expect little now and just
wait to see what they do in the future
as you said they're changing it and my
as it can't be bad but also it's this
way for you to
if they give you a way to grind and you
go hard in one season you should be able
to because now you're gonna guild your
new seal you're not gonna spend multiple
seasons getting it so the gilding may be
something if you're like you know pvp
god whatever the seal is for that one
it's pvp god two three four and then
that's how you flex as opposed to taking
multiple seasons to get something and
maybe
maybe six months down the road you have
a completely different job and now you
can't get it like that that's
frustrating so they're making it
not un easily accessible i think they're
changing the way you get to it so it's
probably not going to be easier but it's
just it will be contained in a season i
would expect yeah and i i don't speak
for all
the sweaties out there
i don't speak for for everyone i'm i'm
probably like less i'm probably more
casual now than i've been in the past
just because the pvp sandbox hasn't been
particularly kind to us faithfuls
um but
i don't think the unbroken seal had that
much meaning to the pvp community
because it was pretty easy to get just
in general like it wasn't it wasn't
you didn't have to like you're the high
percentage
destin has it destin hasn't broken like
have you seen that
under the bus
make sure you make sure his access still
works when he goes back to i'm just
saying man i'm just saying and he did it
through the freelance playlist
exclusively right and it's like
i it just it's just i don't i don't
think i personally
so you looked at the unbroken dudes like
like like that's nice you haven't ever
wear
all i have to say is i for me the
unbroken seal really didn't mean
anything they made it i made it pretty
attainable and i don't think that people
are going to set but more importantly if
we agree that the fundamentals of the
comp playlist wasn't working why the
heck would you want to keep going in
that direction i just think this is rip
the bandit off do we got to do rebuild
it personally i think in nine months you
know okay so i get it now i get it i get
it i think there's a chance i think
there's a chance in nine months when
this comes out that pvp is matter right
whatever that game is i i mean who knows
who knows what it's gonna be i got you
down so basically it was like to travis
like flawless chronicler that i was
gucci balenciaga like that was
um bro was like walmart to you that was
like target
it was more it was more just like
it just didn't represent target are on
different levels by the way just saying
it was kind of a shrug it was like all
right well they they haven't broken but
that doesn't tell me anything that
doesn't tell me if they're like super i
don't get it now okay i got it i got it
and i i wanted to know like if you have
a symbol over your head sometimes it
tells you things about that person if
you see somebody with a blacksmith over
their head oh you know that that person
hates themselves
and
that is that is a very uh important
thing to know when you see a player and
so for me unbroken just meant well i
don't know they could have been into pvp
uh uh three years ago that maybe they
haven't played it in a while maybe they
only do freelance and i just feel like i
want your seal to tell me like something
specific about you like gotcha okay
you guys were getting specific into one
one particular topic but where is the
state of destiny 2's pvp oh god is that
something where you guys are religiously
playing it or you've kind of stepped off
that is not in a good place right now it
is a bit of a fire
made of trash mostly
they haven't added a multiplayer map in
almost two three two two two and a half
years two years
and before that i think the map they
added was just one right and then yeah
they they haven't added any game modes
in a couple years iron banner doesn't
hold the weight it used to or doesn't
it does for grinding if you're trying to
get end game yeah there's four batteries
that give you some pinnacle gear but
outside of that people do the bounties
you have tokens
the iron banner is getting reworked next
season so there will be some changes
okay well hopefully that has that's fine
a little better direct access to loot
iron banner is not a bad event
but it's also stagnant very very badly
stagnant both in the fact that it's
always control
every time it's their little iron banner
tweak on control but that never changes
because we haven't had many modes in a
while
pvp
playlists are basically the same they've
been for a while
and we haven't had much in that we
haven't had new modes the maps as travis
said haven't been put in there in a
while
i mean
they added stuff like freelance and
that's like a big deal when they
announce freelance playlist it's nice so
you're not playing against stacks of six
people and you're just like everybody's
solo but outside of that no pvp has not
got much love honestly in a couple years
so it's due and i think season 19 is
going to be that
let's try and build up pvp
hopefully it's you know there's a decent
pvp focus in 19 right before lightfall
that's why i think this time is the
community speaking out about this i mean
is the community loud and clear or are
they content with their pve no they
you have this weird thing where the pvp
community will say this is a problem and
then you have the other part of the
community which is probably a majority
saying oh you guys don't matter shut up
and yeah that's really nice
it's a really weird like in
in even the people that should be allies
the destiny stands there's like right
weird divide where there's a divide yeah
are convinced that the pvp doesn't
matter in the game and i think that they
only say that because it's in a bad
place and that they're diehard destiny
fans and they don't want to kill your
negativity but it's like it is part of
the game and it's a not good part of the
game and if you want to like hand wave
and go oh well that's not really what
destiny's about then i i think that you
are uh living in in a world that that
does not reflect reality you know just
you know coming from where i was with
the game initially i played a lot of uh
pvp back early on i did and let's just
be honest let's credit to them to what
we've said that's that amazing gun play
the way that it feels there's just not a
lot of games out there like that so
i will say this much though again like i
said mooch has been on the outside
looking in right and i haven't stopped i
haven't stopped looking in because i
missed the community and the one thing i
did notice because i follow bontes you
know i mean you have no idea i follow
what this man does this man eats lives
breathes this game as i'm sure a lot of
other people do too but i i did notice
people starting to taper off from the
pvp and the reason being was the last
time i was back in the pvp we got to go
ways back we got to go back over a year
and i remember when i went back and
revisited it it it it it didn't have the
feel it didn't have the it didn't have
the community it didn't have that that
that appeal and even iron banner kind of
lost a little bit of that it just lost a
little bit of that touch you guys you
remember right destiny remember destiny
early on when it was iron banner week
right i mean crew was on you you took
your phone you shut it off you told
people you were the plague you were like
leave me alone i had i just wanted to
play that until i got my my my gear and
i just you know what it was more than
the gear and i hate to say this because
when it comes to destiny with me the
gear means so much but
it was about playing pvp with my friends
and enjoying that community and i
noticed that as i kept on saying guys
iron banners this week iron banners this
week less and less unless people
came to the party so that's why i asked
this question again i i promised the
chat and i promised the panel tonight
that even though i've been away these
questions are for people that may have
stepped away for a minute they may
listen to the show later on but for me
i'm very interested to hear what you
guys have to say because
you guys literally
you guys sleep eat bleed this game so i
trust your opinions very much and when
you say that that pvp community has take
a hit
uh because of the developers kind of
leaving that to the side i'm with travis
i'm with travis and the fact that this
is part of the game
and i'd even if you enjoy the pve aspect
of it more which by the way i respect
that i totally respect that
you have to
not you can't neglect the other side
that was there from the get-go and and
there's a large portion of people that
play it for that and i was one of those
people i'll call myself a 50-50 on that
one i also enjoyed it so i hope that
when we see these plans
and i see light fall and i see these
other
moving into 2022 into 2023 i hope we see
some sort of a plan from bungie to
revitalize the pvp with a new map with
new modes
um you know listen and i know i'm
cross-referencing this into something
else but cognito you don't mean you've
talked about this a number of times it's
the same thing that i had a concern with
halo infinite it's the same concern i
say here you you launch a game you
launch new expansions you you have to
give people new modes new maps you have
to
and i don't mean that with any
disrespect it's real it's real you know
it's what keeps people engaged
so i hope that what you guys say is true
i hope that the the i'm sure
listen there's no way bungie's not
listening to this very episode right i
mean come on about this let's just be
real listen to e i mean
you know they do so
they do of course they do so i hope they
bring i hope they put a lot of attention
into a travis because it is important
there is that is a large portion of this
game and i personally loved it and i
ironically the pve people who are who
are sort of like pooh-poohing the pvp
community is not being uh central to the
game
you know the ironic thing is they're
sort of cutting off their nose to spite
their face because the pvp community is
always what has kept destiny alive
during content droughts and all that
it's like they they
we're dependent on each other in a
certain way
another mode so yeah
i don't know i i think a lot of the pvp
um
brain trust got moved on to this other
project that bungie's working on and
we'll see if that has any involvement in
the destiny uh the destiny game i i
don't know if it's going to be a fully
separate game or if it's going to have
some sort of tie-in to the destiny
universe or be related in some way or if
you'll be able to pull your account and
your character over to this new game we
have no idea what it is but
i will say to their credit they had they
did spend some time late last year
reworking trials they made this
announcement about the comp playlist
finally and they also said that at some
point they're going to bring back
a um
a
rift one of the modes that they took out
which to be fair some people are like oh
travis what about rift i got that on
twitter a couple times and i was like
yo that's an old mode that they took out
of the game yeah
so like
it's the same thing as them is the same
thing as them putting in an old map that
i've already played on like it's good
it's better than than what i have now
which is nothing but it's not exactly
something uh you know parade in the
streets about so i am super excited
about rift i will play a ton of that
when it comes back but also
let's not give them too much credit we
haven't had a good game mode since since
oh yeah yeah the taking king or
something there's supposed to be a
couple of the game modes literally over
the course of this year we're supposed
to get
theoretically one new map and then one
d1 map over the course of the rest of
year as well that's not a lot now a
couple of modes can help give a lot of
these maps a little bit of life
but we still don't even know what those
are when they're coming i mean season 17
gonna be a mode is season 18 gonna be
rift is season 19 going to be a mode
that's more pvp than we'll have seen in
years which would be nice but again we
still don't know but it does feel like
the fact that they mentioned this for
season 19 feels like that'll be kind of
like where pvp really does get the focus
maybe drop a couple modes throughout the
year might give a little bit of life but
as you guys have said
i just talked about eight eight weeks
not a lot going on in the pve world yeah
you can do some grandmaster stuff but
for if people especially so it'll be hey
i just want to go play some pvp
i enjoy some pvp
and it's like if it's the same stuff
over and over and over you do get tired
and you will go move on if they want
that weekly engagement those other modes
like gambit may be dying in a corner
somewhere that one it's fine but pvp is
still a pd is a part of most games at
this point and if they're finally
starting to show it love
a little bit at a time it can't come
fast enough the more we get on that one
the better just to help these i was
shocked to hear what you just said about
this
you said gambit's holding its own no
gambit's dying in a corner
yeah okay okay well i thought you said
gavin originally can go die in a corner
i thought you said no no it did when i
played that mode i mean i listen that
that just wasn't that wasn't made for me
um i i couldn't get into it cognito i
could not do it i tried i really did
played a bunch of rounds of it i i just
that's not that's not the mode i'm
looking for you know what i mean and i
mean did you guys stick around for long
and i'm not asking you your opinion
today because your opinion today is
about i think we're all on the same page
but when it first came out was it
something that you thought you could get
a grasp on and and stay in tune with or
no absolutely not this was i felt it
wasn't for me almost right from the
get-go
it was weird because i did like it was
funny trav i actually played it with
destiny my first time was playing with
destiny and sean finnegan
ever and i felt like it had potential
potentials things they never developed
yeah right
the peak potential moment is when me and
e got excited like oh okay they're doing
um
what is it the suits with the with this
with the rolls and okay maybe right like
they really take it as serious but
it just it never really well even that's
like that system was like let me earn
armor
right
in another mode that doesn't help me in
that mode but i got to use it over here
like that already is just like no it was
yeah that's you're not helping your game
met this whole one world universe you're
making everything disjointed and that
just didn't help you yeah i agree i
agree no gambit definitely is i don't
mean for i'm sorry for the devs if you
guys are listening to this i know you
guys put some work into this one but it
look it just got patched and we are
going to have gambit labs i don't know
if i'm going to try it or not but gambit
labs is going to switch up the invasions
i might try one or two just to see how
it feels but i mean there's an ornament
that sits there and you have to reset
gambit basically twice to get it
and you've not done that
i have not done i can't even remember
why i i don't think i've got that one
season since it's been an option
i'll do vanguard strikes and i'll do
crucible and get the ornament and the
weapon of the season the pursuit ones i
cannot bring myself to because the
seasonal challenges you can usually skip
to
that is always when i skip
i don't know that's the last thing i'll
say in reference to the pvp part and i
know we're beating this dead horse but
for mooch because he's been away is that
the the thing that i've seen it was it
was a multiple things and and the first
thing was the cheating was just
outrageous that was horrible so it just
destroyed the complete integrity of the
game right so people were literally
paying people going to these sites and
and doing all this you know to get
people through on trials and flawless so
that killed it then you had the whole
pvp pve balance thing where one thing is
op and pvp then they get nerfed and it
affects people so they had that to go
through it then my issue you know was
the rewards like i i came from when you
know you had a
a healthy set when you did iron ban like
you said there was a healthy set of
rewards to go chase and you're like
every week okay what's the reward and
then they started being lazy there
wasn't no rewards like it was just like
what's going on it's been the same gun
for like six months like what's going on
so you had that and then to travis's
point you know and we've talked about
nauseam then they really started not
respecting the hardcore and having a
rank system and and really letting the
hardcore
see where they are right and in the
whole epilogue excellent things and it
was just a snowball effect so what it is
is that they blow it up okay now they
did the end tai chi you know so it's
like this slow
baby yeah they're they were working on
foundational stuff now they're trying to
get like developers in there to work on
making maps and work on making modes
it's like they had the whole team as you
guys have said whatever the alternate
ips are
huge chunks of whatever pvp focused
people
got pulled ripped there's no
ip there's no other way because they
basically just let pvp flounder for
so long so now we're fine like
you know joe blackburn had the 20 tweet
post about hey this is the thing this is
the schedule this is what we're working
on
like he did address it to that point now
we're slowly starting to see a little
bit of time frames a little bit of
commitment to pvp it's slow
but it is a the ball has slowly started
rolling shout out to gaming forte by the
way pvp was my main check but my side
chick pve started treating me better so
i made the decision to leave my girl of
seven years for the amazing side check
oh forte
man it makes sense but i will say can i
just i will say really quickly but it
probably isn't quickly um
just respond to what new rad said in the
chat which is that um he thinks pvp has
hurt destiny more than it's helped it in
the time that it's been around which is
a
completely wrong take and you should be
ashamed of even typing that or thinking
it and i i just because it it it
completely misunderstands the economy
and the vision that that bungie had and
still has even even in the the mistakes
that they've made and it also minimizes
the the kind of impact that that it's
had on the game which is that there
probably wouldn't be a destiny today
without pvp pvp has sustained the game
through droughts that it probably would
not have happened
for sure
it also has the vital role of giving a
sandbox for people to show off the stuff
they've earned without that you're just
shooting at you know
computers that that can't feel the
impact and the weight of what you've
gotten if you if you bring a dope
loadout that you earned in the game into
the pvp sandbox then it starts that
conversation and it just it gives you
that that place to kind of show off and
to use those tools and it it it is an
endgame activity for lots of people and
so i i i get that at times it has hurt
the game because uh people
uh well
yeah
it splits the focus of the team but to
say that it's hurt the game or that's
helped it is
incredibly incredibly wrong and and i
just i can't i don't i i don't know if
if if it's just a complete
misunderstanding of game development or
if you if you just don't like pvp
yourself but um i i just i i can't get
behind that in even even the slightest
sense um that was a very you're wrong
that was a wow travis went in i gotta be
honest with you i will say this much
though i thought travis made a great
point there in saying you know you
acquire this
these weapons right and their
capabilities
and just firing those off at you know
ads or things like that that's one thing
but to fire it off feel that impact as
you hit somebody in pvp
he's dead on accurate with that and
don't tell me that after you got a great
kill in pvp you didn't go ahead and i'll
use one of the lord cognitos a little
bit of a smirk came on your face right
you know what i mean sure so shout out
to travis for really putting that in
perspective i i gotta say as you were
saying that i'm
sitting here saying preach just keep
going on because i do think it's it's a
very important aspect of the game so it
was a great selling point look it's not
some fun for everybody i get it but i i
have to lean try i do feel when pvp is
in a good place
it it can carry destiny and it it
literally i remember man like how's the
house of wolves i remember like that
game was i couldn't get anybody really
to play
and then trials debuted and they didn't
really have a lot of pve content at the
time but that kept the play account
people coming back week to week and
stuff like that so if they could if they
could figure it out the last part i'll
say which is they literally blew up the
building to put a more better foundation
so we got the anti-cheat now they have
to come in the content because the
content just has not been there the maps
the modes and all that and the rewards
and then they got to get in the ranking
system please
i was like it's
i'm very i'm just watching chat i'm
listening to you guys talk
and to me i can't say like pvp has made
things worse are there balancing moments
that are annoying to me when they affect
pve side of things due to the way they
want the coherent sandbox that's the
thing rook sitting there saying why
would i play d2 pvp when there's halo
apex cod other things that are better
pvp games and there are things that are
going to be more focused on pvp i'm
actually not really going to argue that
but there are moments if people want to
spend their time in the destiny universe
you go get a palindrome and a strike
in a nightfall and you get that god roll
pvp where are you going to use a
palindrome
you're going to use it in pvp that's
where that gun is built to be used it is
a 140 with very specific perks that are
good in pvp now is it weird that you get
a pve gun or a pvp gun in pve
yes that weird crossover sometimes is a
bit odd but that's kind of the way they
get you to float back and forth between
i would say honestly
i think pvp
the people who are burned by it and hate
it or and gambit as well
if they didn't force you into eat any of
those so much when say a pve person
didn't want to maybe they just want to
live in pvp pvp or pve i'm going to say
that one too many times and cross it but
if they didn't force you always like hey
for your weeklies and your dailies and
your seasonal challenges and all of the
things if they didn't always like press
somebody to go in there and i know it's
like hey come check out these other part
of the games
it's okay to like steer you there every
so often but it does feel sometimes
especially with the way the playlist
have been snagged them for a while it's
like oh i gotta go do my pvp again and
some of us have been playing so long the
seasonal grind is like i gotta get these
levels up gotta do this thing and it
used to be even worse with like the 50
levels that was worse than it was it
than it is now
so it's been a long time building for
some people where they've been pushed so
much into those activities when they
haven't been in a great state i can see
that but me i also don't think it has
made the game
worse either because there are times
i'll go in pvp yeah i have moments where
i'm like oh god why am i facing a three
stack but looks like they've got a
thousand flawless runs like this is so
broken but on the other side i'll go in
in a trials match and i pull out a zero
to four and come back five to four and
win that thing and i have an amazing
moment in trials pvp and i'm going
it's not all bad again it's not all good
but there's something to
playing against again this is why they
said it in the first place take those
guns you've earned in the world and go
shoot pvp players it feels different and
has that unique experience every time as
you guys have said they carry through so
many droughts over the course of this
eight year history we have you can't
disregard that there are better things
than destiny pvp but i also think there
are things that you know the space magic
is unique i love mayhem every so often
just to burn off some steam it is just
stupid fun and i wish honestly they
would do things like momentum control
where guns feel different like you know
one trigger pull on a pulse rifle bam
it's just
that's the type of stuff i wish they had
more of
so there are they need to experiment
more with their yeah i agree absolutely
absolutely
so yeah i think i think
the problem right now is is not that the
gun play sucks and the destiny is like
unsavable it's just that they haven't
nurtured the that part of their sandbox
that part of their game it just it just
needs
it needs uh maintenance
yes that sort of
building on and then that sort of thing
but it's not just completely dead
because oh halo made a good pvp sandbox
well there's only allowed to be one good
game at a time so
i guess destiny should just close up
shop everybody just play halo that's
just not how it works like i can't bring
vex mythoclasts into halo right i can't
i can't bring my p my pve
accomplishments into it into apex
legends and just
i can't do that and so i i think uh i i
think
they they can fix it and i know they can
because it's it's bungee damn it i know
they can fix it like they are the pvp
master so i just want um
i want them to do it and i'm sure we'll
get it in time but
of course it's frustrating
listen i always consider it a core
pillar i mean they they could they have
a pinnacle for it every week they
consider it a core pillar just by their
actions the way they want you to level
they wouldn't have it in a pinnacle
category if it didn't so i agree i just
think if it's if it's if it's done right
it's in a good place and what makes it
what makes destiny so unique you have
these different things that make
compiles this great package and you just
want everything to be treated equally
yeah
so
being is the pve side of things is in a
very good spot
not perfect but very very good
and now we're seeing potential with pvp
having
light it's pretty far out there on
horizon but we got a little light
there's light there's
the switch at the very far end of the
tunnel has actually been flicked on like
well
now we know we're in a tunnel
yeah we were just in a dark we were in
that part in elden ring where you have
to pull out the torch otherwise you
don't know what's around you yes and now
like somebody's always somebody lit the
torch on the other side of the giant
warehouse and now you're like all right
there's a direction so there we go
uh coming up we will have trials
freelance on the 8th and then this
coming weekend trials is going to be
zone capture so if you are jumping in
trials got a little mix-ups i wish
freelance was next to permanent
i know
just because i'm not joking
yeah i mean it's like just give it as an
option three stacks only and freelance
only the whole two pair i'm sorry but
yeah at that point the two pairs
probably just need to go
but either way uh we've got a hotfix
coming up so again no holding zero
hostage a couple random things um is
there anything else you guys want to
touch on with is trying to ask a
question about trials too because it's
been a very long time since i've
revisited that is trial still for the
elite is it still for that upper you
guys don't know what i'm talking about
though right yeah remember when it was
just
they casualized it pretty hard last year
how'd they do that travis what did they
do to actually bring that down to earth
um yeah i mean this is a very long
conversation
okay make it short make it short
give me give me the short short version
travis
um
they made it more accessible they made
it rewarding even if you don't win
um they uh added options like freelance
where you don't have to play with a full
team um and they created a way where if
you win at trials
you go into a separate playlist where
you don't play with people who haven't
won yet so as the weekend goes on you uh
you have a better chance of winning
because you're playing okay appears more
often okay so
they they definitely made it less of
like a mountaintop it's not unattainable
if you play
if you play even
you know you try moderately you'll get
there like i usually get there on my
first ticket now it's not really much of
a challenge when i when i do play it but
does it no but travis now since because
cognito nibanta said basically we opened
up a can of worms here oh my god is it
has these changes
pissed you off in a sense is it oh he
is
asking everything this man
has just fought and died for him
he's literally twisting every knife into
the gut like i'm just sitting there like
boots know what he doing
[ __ ] they wanted me for 60 minutes but i
turned them down listen i gotta be
honest with you right
travis i mean what is what is it because
and i'm dying to know because this is
there's a reason that someone like
myself that i love a challenge i i love
that it's why i play my souls games it's
why when people said you can't play
eternal i platinum did i don't care if
you say i can't
i want to you know what i mean so my
point being so travis this was something
in trials that someone like myself said
i got to get good it sounds like they
made it so you can just
yeah so play the game and you know
it's more nuanced than cog in ear are
making i think which is that i'm not
upset that they that they made trials
more accessible and and rewarding for
people who who uh aren't as sweaty right
i don't i don't care about that the
thing that i don't like is that there's
currently in destiny no end game
activity for pvp if you want to
play competitive the competitive
playlist doesn't actually pit you
against people in your ranking or skill
bracket and trials now no longer does
that either it no longer represents that
super difficult activity and so there's
this gap that's left and so when we were
discussing this cog and e were saying
this is great trials is dying as a mode
this is what they have to do to make it
survive which i agree with it was dying
as a mode but my hope was that they
would go the other way and they would
fix it by making it a good competitive
mode and they went the other way and
basically just gave up on having a
competitive end game activity and so now
my hope is that they're going to take
the comp playlist and make that what
trials isn't and trials will become more
iron bannerish which i'm totally fine
with i don't need to feel like i get
this mode that's just mine and because
i'm the best of the best i get the best
loot oh that's not good
that's not what he loses at all that's
not what it is at all what i want is i
want to be able to see where i rank i
want to know my rank and i want to have
that goal of like oh i want to level up
i want to get from from uh
diamond to platinum diamond you know
whatever the thing is i want to get from
silver to gold i want to see that kind
of like
you know i'm i iron a sharpening iron
i'm becoming like a better weapon i'm
i'm ranking up and i want there to be
some sort of like
in rocket league or whatever the higher
rank you get up to at the end of the
season you get rewards based on the
highest rank you achieve that sort of
stuff like i just think that that sort
of system would be fantastic in destiny
i hoped that trials would be that system
and they were like no we have different
plans for trials but now we're seeing
maybe the refreshing comp and maybe comp
will be that thing i just want there to
be an end game mode yeah um and it's i'm
not upset about trials or anything like
that but i i want there to be an end
game activity for pvp desperately and
that's fair
that's where i stand hey the twab this
week actually gave you a glimmer of hope
that that might be something they're
working on so and that's why i wasn't
upset right if i was upset with this
then you guys would like my dogs up
there trying to be like do something
come on do something it's not fun if
y'all don't let me create the narrative
of what y'all oh
yeah
i gotta make you the person i got these
two out here that make me be like hold
on i gotta like i gotta eat my food with
just bone dry with no flavor all pl i
eat boiled chicken and that's it and i'm
just like exactly and i gotta make trav
the most snobbish elitist that i could
possibly make so it fits my doubt if
you're not helping my narrative right
now yeah you gotta you gotta let you
gotta let cognito do his thing too right
this is what he does yeah
he likes building he likes building
straw man that's yeah uh that's his
band he's a guy that's right i am an
instigator or some lover i
he's like oh this podcast is too calm so
what i'm gonna do it's like okay we
gotta talk about trials i gotta poke
holes oh yeah come on you know yeah
we got food coming up oh we got we got
that's true you're right you guys are
fun because you know when you got
personality
that's right you got to press the button
that warms that seat up that's just the
way that it is that's just the way it is
you know the vibes
the only landmine that mooch avoided
during this episode was bringing up the
playstation acquisition that's really
the only uh hot button we didn't touch
we didn't have to at least brush up
again well as we seem to be wrapping up
with our destiny content oh the
playstation no we'll not we won't talk
about the acquisition i was actually
going to talk about just the activities
for the week nah we ain't doing that um
no i wanted to see for one
uh game delays nintendo obviously
dropping
zelda a little farther out to 2023
somewhere in the spring which could be
like june 30th or
somewhere in there uh and then we've
also got playstation dropping their
playstation plus
tiers not a competitor we're not going
to
you know we don't feel this is how we
can make the quality of games that we do
and all those things i haven't listened
to defining duke yet i feel like that
just probably dropped and you guys
talked about it um but anybody's take on
basically the big playstation
subscription thing because a lot of
people do play games on playstation so
this is a big change for playstation
so and i know the world of outside
destiny chat is mooch's wheelhouse a bit
more than it is right now but tomorrow
this man's gonna be a destiny expert but
my entire life changes my entire life
changes the minute ivanta says the
show's over i have to immediately jump
into destiny so trust me uh i'll be
trying to mooch my way back onto this
podcast don't you worry about it ladies
and gentlemen
but you know
if you don't mind i'll take the mic real
quick i think that when it comes down to
it i think a lot of people that are on
this on this panel
uh
very fortunate by the way very important
you know i shout the lord cognito and
the ilp crew for doing what they do man
outstanding work day in day out week in
week out
um but i do want to say this much you
know we're fortunate cog and i say this
all the time you know i had the great
jeff grubb on on crossfire a few weeks
ago jeff jeff discussed he discussed the
tears point blank
and you know for the most part he he
knocked the home run right out the park
you know he called what it was it's
three tiers what this is this is a
rebranding right right now you've got a
situation where ps plus does very well
ps now not so much but it's because
people don't really know what ps now is
when ps now also came out it was also
known as just a streaming service well
now it's kind of a merge right there's
certain things that you can download
right to your console there's certain
games you're going to have to stream
still that seems to be a problem that
they've been having with the ps3 et
cetera et cetera you guys know all that
we're not going to bore anybody with
that on the show
but when it comes down to it
we've already been told what this was
going to be ivantis so when i saw the
breakdown i saw what it was i said okay
they rebranded it they renamed it and
they gave it i thought i thought i'll
say this much i'll call it fair pricing
only reason i'm saying fair pricing is
because i'm just gonna stick with my
normal ps plus
i've got ps plus right now for about two
three years paid out guess what
whatever they're gonna give me in that
rollover that's where i'm staying i'm
gonna get my you get your free games
monthly like you get now you get to play
online and you know i know everybody
this is a point of contention but you
get your cloud saves whatever my point
being is that's where i'm staying so i i
don't really have a leg in the race this
was clearly this was clearly right
you've had playstation executives come
out and say it you've had people in the
media i believe bloomberg even came out
and said it weeks before so give jason
schreier his credit too okay that this
is not a game pass competitor i don't
know why people kept on running with
that notion it's clear that sony's not
going to be doing day and date that's
what makes game pass game pass let's
just put that right there okay
it's not the fact that it gets one or
two or three even four of the aaa games
day and date from a third party it's the
fact that their first party will
inevitably when it gets right when
they're ready to do so will be their day
and date right now you're seeing sony
with games okay let's even take um
ghost of tsushima selling uh over 8
million 10 million copies right you've
got your god of wars or spider-man's
doing over 20 million copies i truly do
believe horizon forbidden west may flirt
with 20 million don't know if it'll get
there but in its lifespan it'll flirt
with it they're in a position and
cognito we talked about this on
crossfire multiple times they're in a
position right now where
sony does not feel that type of pressure
to be able to do that and you guys know
this the reason i totally bought this in
my homework assignment for the show
about the restaurant business right was
the fact that like when it comes down to
it you know whether you're going out um
to celebrate your anniversary your
birthday doesn't matter what it is you
go to this favorite restaurant because
they have your favorite dish
and that dish is not recreated anywhere
else it's a recipe okay it could be the
way that the sauce is prepared it can
even be the way
whatever it is that floats your boat the
point of the matter sony has a recipe
with their games right now where they
know that they can get the sixty seventy
dollars from each individual okay we're
still saying six into a ps4 game but 70
for ps5 they know they can get that and
then they can plunk that game down into
a ps now subscription based service 12
16 18 24 months later at their leisure
and then they can throw it also on pc
another 12 24 36 months at their leisure
and you say well mooch where's your
evidence the evidence right there is god
of war horizon for uh
horizon zero dawn um i believe you also
have um
that stranding these are games that came
out years ago on the playstation
platform and then absolutely sell like
hot pancakes right
on the pc platform and they're doing
very well to also promote the ps now
subscription so
sony knows what they have in their ip if
their ip starts to falter the quality
starts to diminish
i think that's why they always say
things can change and things can change
on a moment's notice with microsoft the
situation with game pass is their games
were not selling as well they also went
into a bit of a snag towards the ends of
xbox one they didn't develop a lot their
first party okay i believe that last uh
new aaa game we got from microsoft was
uh cf thieves and that was 2018. guys
please correct me if i'm wrong so my
point being with all this rambling is
that microsoft said hey we've got to do
something radical and we've got to do
something that really alerts and gets
the the consumer's attention and they
did so they did sell with game pass
um
so when i saw this news in my bontes
because i want to hear the rest of the
panel's thoughts on it
again no shock factor thanks to the guys
that did like the the jason schreier's
the jeff grubs out there these guys told
us what was coming down the pipeline i
knew that even if one or two small
nuances that they left out
we would get the other day i knew it
wasn't going to be anything that would
be revolutionary and make you fall out
of your chair so again i think the
pricing is decent
i think the shock factor is at minimum
they rebranded it for people so now you
can actually combine the two services in
one and let's not forget something
nintendo's very similar with their
online right they've got an amazing back
catalog of games that are just beloved
from all the nes guys like we were
talking about earlier on the show all
the way up till today sony has that same
golden bullet with their historic and
beloved
uh classic titles okay they've got 700
titles or something that nature that you
could possibly get 340 titles up front
uh
my point being is that that's what
they're trying to lure people in with
and because before they were separated
with two separate uh packages and prices
now you can actually get that with one
combined price it makes it easier they
gave it a simple name to understand and
they rebranded it i don't think it gets
any more complex than that if you guys
know something i don't
or there's a reason that i'm missing out
like i said i am not going to tear up
i'm happy in the tier that i'm at right
so um
i think that's basically the long and
short of it about this yeah i gotta hear
what dog has to say because uh
the defining duke episode 65 the xbox
game pass quotes killer has arrived uh
that's also just for the choice of uh
clickbait but uh i wanted to get your
take custody there's no no i know that's
that's how you get people to click on
that affordable on that too i was like
we really do that he's like
it's not based i think the whole when
you click on it you know what i mean no
i was like no it'll get the clicks but i
was going to ask cog you're kind of the
other side generally because you know
yeah no look you know i mean i agree for
the most part what we said i mean
to me this is just a consolidation of
two services you know that's what this
is like this is simple revolutionary to
me
in that respect so it's just like
playstation now wasn't really doing well
you know playstation plus is doing
phenomenal there's a tier there you
rolled it in
you know i'm of the mindset this way and
i kind of said it on duke like
you know
it's values in the eye of the beholder
you know what what game pass is doing is
great right it's day
phenomenal value great awesome you know
i love all that stuff
but to much his point i will say yeah
like
they're in a position where they don't
have to necessarily do that that might
not be their business model to say hey
we're going to put our first party stuff
i mean almost in the same vein of
nintendo in the sense that like you know
they have an identity for the third
person over-the-shoulder cinematic
amazing type experience right and they
also like hey we feel our games are 70
or whatever right but the market is
going to dictate the market's going to
dictate so
until the market says yo we're not
feeling this you know i'm saying or till
we have let's say we have a bunch of
gran turismo moments and we don't feel
the quality is up to stuff or whatever
then it will change i think when you're
in the position of winning the last
generation you don't necessarily have to
automatically match now but the key for
them is going to be
will this show like will this model
be sustainable will this be will people
gravitate towards if people gravitate
towards as business as usual then they
got the algorithm they got the metrics
that's going to show you know that hey
we could stay here and it's fine you
know what i'm saying the only thing
though i will the only thing i disagree
with is that i do feel that they have
alluded that it is a game pass
competitor only because when jim ryan
was asked specifically hey what are you
gonna do with game pass and he literally
was just like yeah we got news to come
for that you know so in their minds
they wanted to position themselves is it
apples to apples no but they wanted to
position their services in a way that
they have something attractive and you
know look i'm with much again
second tier is me you know i'm fine
where i'm at i'm not necessarily
thrilled about the third tier and giving
me streaming games and then you're
naming games and i don't know what these
games are over 400 of what like what
what's in the game
i think that's one of the biggest
questions
i'm not interested in the demo until i
can see until i until you show me the
difference here is this
when you had the game pass situation
i had a list
of
here is everything that's going to
compile here are the 100 or 200 whatever
the number is right i just don't know
i'm not saying that it's not going to
have value i just i just don't know what
it is so i'm more in a wait and see
show me what the the higher tier is
going to offer me before i go balls to
the wall and and throw the highest tier
money at them and that's it but that's
where i'm at with it i'm curious where
you guys are no i think i think just
real quick just the rebuttal i think i
think laura cognito nailed it but i i
think when it comes first of all they're
gonna they're gonna announce the games
that are gonna be part of that 370. so i
think that's going to be announced
before the june launch
um the other part of it is is that you
know it's
it really is interesting though because
a lot of people were really excited
about xcloud right and me and cognito
also had a great conversation about this
in the past
you know i myself personally i'm not a
big ex cloud
fan i don't feel like streaming my games
um but a lot of people are down on sony
for the streaming aspect so they're down
on the sony streaming games right but
then they're like the very next tweet is
i can't wait to get home or when i'm on
the road i'm going to use xcloud so you
can't really say right you don't so you
don't have the download option
yeah that's the thing the download
dollar option's not there but on xcloud
if you're on your phone you don't either
so i mean my my point being is the
people saying that i can't wait to play
destiny on my phone
i've seen people that are saying i i i
don't want to stream a game on my
console on my account
differences
they want the choice because the thing
is at home at least with 360 you can
download the game
to your dev to your console and play it
on a local level whereas this you're
forced to stream it even if you're at
home
let me know because you know because i
know you've probably tried it out i have
not so when you download something on
your 360 or your xbox one
right
well like series x but seriously well
series x right so my point being though
real quick is is you're talking about
native i'm talking about xcloud
okay i'm not talking about i'm not
talking about gameplay
that's different
but when you have ultimate
that are saying gameplay love xcloud
i'm just saying
it's that's streaming
it is so yeah
right but i'm just trying to say here
because xcloud's included with ultimate
game pass yeah but i think they're two
different people there's people who are
excited about gamepad or xcloud and then
there's people who there are different
people travis that are excited about
that but there are also the same person
tweeting out i love x-cloud i don't like
streaming sony games yeah i'm just
saying you're right as well there's
always
when it comes down to it this wasn't
necessarily and to answer cogs point on
this too a lot of times this happens on
podcasts happens on shows all the time
you know people speak fast interview
they speak fast jim ryan probably
misspoke there
i got the quote
right gave an interview to the task
he said nobody was really expecting
somebody to do anything so ryan's answer
is surprising there is actually news to
come just not today you know so
his mind they did have something that is
going to compete because it's competing
in a subscription service yes absolutely
so it is that that that's what i'm
saying so he answered the question they
had pieces right they actually had it
before game pass
so my point being is that they're like
what they wanted to do is rebrand their
structure because it was an absolute it
was a mess as far as finding like if you
didn't know you're like i have to
subscribe to ps plus they want to put
this together and have that package
together
microsoft had done it neat and clean so
but again it's it's nowhere near it's
not the same
we're just talking apples and oranges we
really really are because when you don't
have the first party games going in day
and date
that's what game pass is first and
foremost period period you take the fact
out that microsoft's new 34 studios take
all those games that they're gonna make
and not put them in there
game pass loses a lot of hype
it loses a lot of hype there's no way
around it because i mean travis we just
spoke before the show right playing
elden ring playing horizon forbidden
west playing wonderlands
listen i only got so much sand in the
hourglass i ain't got time for tunic
sorry i don't i want to i don't
so yeah you know the point of the matter
if you take this but you've got time for
halo infinite on day one you've got time
for star field on day one that's what
would i just say those are the i said if
you pull those out if those aren't there
is it what it is
no yeah if you change the the that's why
what people say is is with sony's
pitching
i'm like it's not the same pitch
it's not the same pitch
i think that's a strength because i i
was a little worried about the spartacus
announcement because
i don't want sony to try to compete with
microsoft using their model i think sony
has a model that's distinct and unique
and it works they've got their wall
they've got their walled garden some
people prefer that xbox has got their a
little bit more accessible kind of open
just player games
model and i think i think that's great
and then nintendo is uh the wild card
they they have their own model and it
super works for them and so when i first
heard about this what i thought was if
if sony chases
microsoft they're going to lose and
they're going to get beat with the
cudgel of microsoft's uh
of of their economic weight the fact
that their wallet they can afford their
wallet yeah they've they're a powerhouse
so i i think um
that
this is more of a reorganization whereas
game pass is a is revolutionary game
pass is trying to be revolutionary it's
saying hey we're gonna do away with the
old model and the new model is you just
pay subscription and you get access to
all the xbox games that's revolutionary
kind of shift playstation is staying
we're keeping our old one the old model
works just fine it works there's a lot
of money with it
uh but here's a place where you can you
know have access to the the bargain bin
it's like you know you look at the top
ten you look at the top ten games that
are being played on xbox right now and
in the top three is a game called eldon
ring
seventy dollars folks
for sure the model doesn't not work it
does work
so sure my point being is that model
does work
so yeah that's the thing so sony knows
that and when it's not broke you don't
fix it now i agree again like i said the
reason i think microsoft went so radical
was because what they were doing before
wasn't working
so like you said travis this what you're
doing is revolutionary yeah it is but
but they're trying to we'll find out if
it's revolutionary it's still a work in
progress um and i think
i mean i would say it's definitely
revolutionized the people that want to
play that like there's there's i have
friends who who are not real they're not
super hardcore gamers they maybe buy one
or two games a year and now they just
pay for game pals and i see them playing
all these different types of games they
never would have touched so i would say
the experiment is successful it's just
it's just a matter of it's like if you
said my friends used to walk by the
arcade in the mall then you handed them
a bunch of quarters and all of a sudden
they're trying all these different games
then they come out you go which one did
you like you're like oh maybe the one
way in the back over there kind of i
don't know what it's called but you know
i liked it so my point being is that i
get more people are trying games it's
more accessible
but myself i have the opposite story i
have a lot of friends of mine that are
casual when we say casual they pay one
or two games a year right they'll buy uh
nba 2k my one good friend and they'll
buy call of duty to them a 15
subscription a month
that doesn't interest them in the least
because they don't know what uh tunic is
they don't know what death's door is
they don't they don't know what these
they don't know what the ascent is they
don't know what the medium is and
frankly for those folks which by the way
we all sit here and go that doesn't
matter it does matter because if you
really want to be successful and you
look at the subscription policies across
the other brands that are out there like
disney plus and and netflix and all
these other ones right that we compare
it all against which we shouldn't this
media's consumed completely differently
than anything on netflix or disney plus
but they have 200 million subscribers
and they're still in debt and they're
going to be in debt up until 2024 2025
according to analysts so my point being
is here you have 25 million right and
you are trying to grab that casual
market the casual market doesn't know
what tunic is the casual market doesn't
care that so so when we say that we have
friends that try it and they dabble they
do try it and they dabble the question
is are they going to retain them and
that's why i say it's still a work in
progress a lot of people are already
waving in the flag like they want
we don't know yet and it's really going
to come down to the the microsoft first
party studios to impress because not
only does that mean that they're going
to try to grab the casual but they need
to impress to retain the hardcore and
that's an important thing to really kind
of realize here and we won't really know
our first real test beta wasn't halo
okay it wasn't forza horizon 5. it's
starfield we're going to start right
there and we're going to move forward
we're going to see how that these teams
do that they acquire i think that's a
pretty arbitrary way to start it i don't
know yeah
that's your first big game in that's
your first big splash from your big
acquisitions i think that's a huge that
is the way to start that that's awesome
to ever not do well fortunate always did
but you could disqualify it to the
surface
they acquired that company it was a that
was a new company for them too if that's
playground well they okay well they also
acquired the ip for gears that wasn't
there as epic was making that but i mean
we still kind of say that's always been
a a microsoft property for all practical
purposes playground that's fine i just i
guess i just don't understand the logic
of hand waving that it seems like
they've proven that
that there is an interest in that's 25
million you would say
you would say that forza horizon 5
getting over a 90 metacritic which it's
always pretty much gotten is a measure
of success for game pass
no i i would say that people subscribing
to game pla pass and playing it and
having access to it
via their subscription is proof that it
works it's it's people well 25 million i
i still think relatively low when you're
talking about the actual number of
subscription based products out there i
mean 25 million after five years it's a
it's a smaller market the the games in
netflix are not the market is actually
taking over the games market's uh making
more money now than the movie market
different thing
is different than users there's no
grandmother with a game passive
subscription
from the beginning you're proving my
point from the beginning it's consumed
differently so it's not necessarily
something that people want to dive in
and subscribe to because you only have
so much time so when someone says
there's 200 games in there well i can
only play one game a month at a time
especially when we have a podcast like
we're doing right now with destiny
destiny consumes a large portion of your
time and then you try to play one other
game you guys know how difficult that is
we talked about it earlier before the
show so to say i have 200 games waiting
for me that are also in a revolving door
don't stay there forever it's not a
vault
it's not necessarily always for
everybody whether it be hardcore or
casual in the casual market it's even
more difficult to get into that's what
certainly i'm saying that's absolutely
it's certainly not for everyone but it's
not like xbox is saying look we're
throwing out the old model this is the
new one they're saying here's another
option
absolutely not but i mean when it comes
down to when you look at the other
things look at third-party games that
we've released numbers for right whether
it be elden ring or any of these games
you'll see that almost 46 to 53 by on
the playstation market and very low buy
on the xbox mark and the reason being is
they are really pushing forward the xbox
brand is game pass so it's like it's
almost like that's the way that they're
kind of marketing it is it the only way
no you're absolutely not there's options
there are options but also don't forget
everybody on this panel and everybody
that's listening to the show has their
ear to the ground in this business
right so the point of the matter is like
it just depends i just i think right now
i think game pass is a weight like like
cognito said with spartacus basically i
still am in the wait and see category
because 25 million a lot of that 25
million is the hardcore xbox that bought
in right you need to get to that 100 150
200 million that's where you've reached
that casual market that's where you
start to see not only success on the
microsoft side as far as revenue but you
start to really see that as being a
presence in the gaming market period how
it's being consumed so i think right now
that's why i said when you see star
field and you see what's going to happen
with avowed and you see what's going to
happen with the games coming down the
road that's really a testament to how
you're going to lure in your newer
customers i mean halo gears and forza
we've all been here for the ride the
since what you are the hardcore you
can't
[Music]
the halo market has always been their
cognito and look at the halo right now
has left the top 10 on the xbox platform
and it's not even getting 9 000
sometimes players on steam absolutely
as far as engagement absolutely but
that's not me or the hardcore that's
just numbers
the number the numbers also dictated in
mpd that it didn't have a negative
effect
on the sales of the game when it
released into game pass
i said the hardcore will always back it
up that's nothing to do with me that's
the hardcore went out there and bought
that game we're in the early stages i
agree right but we have to be careful as
hardcore gamers based on what we consume
right that that's what the market's
going to be the casual market is going
to dictate a lot of this stuff too so
i'm with you on acquisitions i'm with
you on
sustainability i'm with you there i'm
with you that the game the first party
game studios that they acquire have to
produce quality content to maintain
people in the service that's 100 percent
100 percent star field you know has to
hit now they get a hit
at least a good portion yeah you're
never gonna hit a home run out of
everyone right that's not fair
absolutely where i definitely see where
they're going is you talked about your
friend and you said the friend that he
buys the call of duty i know that friend
too i know that we all have that friend
the call of duty absolutely madden and
whatever and that's it right that's it
that's guess what they just acquired
activism right so yeah we'll do these in
the service well well you're right
correct they're in the process right but
a lot of assuming if
if all intents and purposes it
seems that it may go through and if it
goes through then they will have call of
duty in this service right
that's a different
that's a different conversation right
then
they have ea the madden guy right so it
becomes a point that if you start to get
these games and then you you market it
correctly and you do what you're
supposed to do then they're going for
that market and the value proposition
but i'm with you it's i'm with you only
we need to see how this thing goes but
the only thing i just want to be clear
we we have as the hardcore we have to be
careful that because we
don't see value as something like i'm
just saying we're smarter because like
me personally it's not for me but to
your point mulch right
there could be a guy that says yo
i get all these playstation collection
stuff i get my god of war i get like
osushima yeah all this this is great i
don't care what cognito talking about
this is fire you know so it's it all is
going to be
how that casual consumes it and if these
if somebody even has to change because
this i'm with you in the sense of this
and travis said this point as well
they have their own model right like you
said if it's not broke don't fix it
right right so if it it the market's
going to dictate if this thing works and
if it does they'll stay status quo and
stand by that and it's up to microsoft
to do what they're doing 100 percent see
how it plays that's 100
i do think it's a little it's a little
pessimistic to
say that the microsoft's model hasn't
proven itself yet i i just think i find
that well i mean there's there's nothing
there's nothing showing massive success
either 25 million subscribers
million that you're talking about answer
that
well well i'm saying to you right now
that there's analysts that have come out
and said that in order for microsoft to
actually make the money that they want
to see it's over a hundred believe it's
over 100 million subscribers that would
start to pass the break-even mark i mean
there's a lot of money going out well do
we consider success if microsoft is
making money because i don't well
wipe their butt with our salaries that's
not an issue of money because they make
so much
that's something's not doing well it
gets cut
netflix
things aren't making noise it's not
about you making five percent off of
this nobody's making money off of this i
don't care either do you think maybe i
have 25 million paying customers
think microsoft caught mixer because it
was not getting the money that they
thought it was going to be making coming
in that's all i'm saying i'm not talking
about 25 billion customers there's 25
million i i just think like what i'm
trying to say to you that's a different
business market than this said earlier
you said earlier that xbox
the game pass is mostly just hardcore uh
players subscribing to it i don't think
there's anything approaching i think
that's a good amount there's nothing
approaching 25 million hardcore xbox
customers in the world they're just
there's just not that many
xbox hardcore players okay
quick by the way
online streams
maybe not 25 million 25 million you know
anything with subscriptions though
travis goes up and down so they said 25
million do you think it never drops
below that
have you ever had a subscription where
you also left it and then came back that
number fluctuates so it's not 25 million
and it can never go below it so there's
times where it's at 18 then it goes
something that peaks up it'll go up this
26. and then it'll drop again that
happens on all subscription services
even gym memberships
i don't know what the reasoning is
between
behind minimizing its success because it
is a significant uh accomplishment and
it's also something that's helping
gamers and giving them more options and
it doesn't the second part is 100 right
we just don't we don't know the success
rate so they don't share any numbers
travis we don't know anything about it
except for 25 million right so we know
25 million if you want to say 25 million
a success i'll go ahead and say on the
show that's fine for you what i'm saying
is they don't reveal anything else
behind it so i just don't i guess maybe
maybe i have less of a stake in if the
company's succeeding or not but to me
it's not about the company's success
it seems it seems like it
is looking at everything whether they're
making money and i mean if the game
doesn't make money or doesn't sell well
you don't get a sequel right or you
don't get any more of the product like
that's just business right so what i'm
saying is if you're a fan of game pass
you wanted to do well right you'd want
it to continue to do well so you'll get
more games and more purchases and more
revenue
that's that's just how we continue the
bit so you're saying it's not about
caring how much they make i don't lose
sleep over that now there's anybody else
on the show but like you do have to say
that you would want them to do well in
order to continue the method in the
program right i personally don't care i
know that it is a success for 25 million
people
okay
okay and so so it's successful for 25
million people i don't care if the
company's making money then again i i i
know you and cog come from a different
world of of like fandoms that i have no
interactions i'm good i'm good so you
know where the fandom world no but i
hear you i think that right no i think
well no but i think that it comes down
to like you say you don't care in the 25
million there was a lot of people that
worked very hard on mixer and you saw
the twitter responses that people were
no they were genuinely pissed coc people
put a lot of time and effort into that
right all of a sudden it just
disappeared and those people that were a
part of mixer are like the 25 million
you're saying they were happy they were
like we're streaming they actually left
twitch they left their fan base there to
come over
they would have said the same thing you
said travis they would be like i don't
care how microsoft's doing right now all
i know is mixer is amazing they are
better than twitch they're treating me
better no latency love it
and then it was gone why because it
didn't do well so what i'm saying to you
is if you're enjoying it you also do
want them to succeed in order for it to
continue that's all i'm saying it's
quite simple i'm not saying anything
more or less than that i just think that
we need to see a little bit more and i
hope it does grow
he's not convinced i'm in gameplay
i hear you
it's not like i don't have it
i just think it needs it it needs to do
well that's all i mean listen this is
where i got to give e because he's been
patient um
yeah he's very patient listen at the end
of the day i've used the analogy i don't
go to the car dealership when they have
a good deal and say
how am i able to get this deal at this
price i just don't do that i'm like oh
this is the deal this is what you're
offering me yes please thank you we're
going to have another and that's it so
whether they choose the garage sales is
their business like that when you when
you got
when you bought that pontiac that was
brand new and it was a good price and
then they just stopped supporting
pontiac after they said like going gm
well i'm just trying i'm giving you an
example
at the price that i like right and what
happened to them is their business 100
but when you invest in that product you
do want that product to continue
with the deal i like that's what i care
about all that their sales and what
happened
this is this is
this is well i'm learning why you got
your reputation first off
gk battles 50 super chat warlocks are
the best nice g iron lord podcast i want
to have your
babies wow
can you buy me a drink first
[Laughter]
straight to the action ty
of course lots of hype and yes thank you
gk for the super
chat somehow an announcement about
playstation's tears has turned into a
debate
about the effectiveness of xbox's game
pass
now
well
yeah we're gonna actually take turns
talking for a second here as opposed to
talking over everybody at the same time
anyway all i wanted to say is
if you look at something like the value
of game pass and somebody's like hey
i've got a kid what should i get him
right game pass is an amazing value
does that person care if microsoft is
making money no because they have to pay
120 for windows every damn time they
want to do it and so it's like that's
right the grand scheme of their business
is doing fine playstation they're doing
a completely separate thing nintendo is
on its own crazy island somehow still
making money because their ips are
amazing they do make good games all of
those things oddly work
and when it comes to playstation it is
getting to a point where as you guys
have said it perfectly it is
consolidation under the title of
playstation plus with different tiers
i'm kind of with you guys as well i want
to see what these 740 games are the only
ones that you're gonna have to stream
look like ps3 everything else seems to
be downloadable depending on what you're
looking for
they still regret the cell processor to
this day which is so sad
but also on the other side i want my v
to games too
oh they had ps yeah somehow they have
psp and not veto that is weird i love
you but either way it's like
typically like the whole i mean somebody
said it in chat should i be paying for
backwards compatibility that seems a
little weird and xbox is doing some very
has done some good stuff with backwards
compat and fps boost and all those
things now they may have run out of
options from i feel like you guys have
talked to somebody there's there's only
so much in that well that they can go to
there may be more as they get to it but
it's like they've done a lot for that so
playstation is feeling a little nintendo
e when they're saying hey you want to
play these old ps3 games you got to pay
for a subscription how long is that one
going to be on the other side we've got
xbox saying hey here's some old games
some new games and some day one games
well what mooch is talking about is
saying
star field is a major moment halo was a
moment forza was a moment those were no
small feats now granted halo
it's been talked enough to death
obviously the live service part of the
model
i mean you could have been in the delay
the game camp if you wanted to at this
point to see it come out with forge yeah
exactly you could see it come out with
ford see it come out it affects the
problem yeah just that they weren't
ready for games as a service model yeah
so it's like that's the story of every
games as a service yeah
destiny is trying to get feeling kind of
good eight years later somehow they've
just limped into this point so you've
got all these pieces that work the
question is you as much you said you've
got 30 studios if activision comes in
with call of duty and then you've got
these other 30 studios that they can
line up a games like a marvel release
schedule that's going to make that thing
an amazing value for day and date and
that's the point where playstation might
be like
damn that is a hell of a value and
they've and it's you know a couple years
from now that is just undeniable but on
the other side playstation's gonna go
god of war they're going to do whatever
comes after that and those 70 titles
like returnal is something that got
enough acclaim i'm glad to see
that it is actually like it got a free
expansion and you have these little
pieces that come on the other side there
are different ways to solve different
problems and honestly this is something
none of us are going to know the answer
to for years
so it's like 100 i was like i'm very
curious to see where all of this stuff
lands because as you guys said until i
see that list of games i'm not touching
my playstation tier no and i'm more of a
playstation guy than
xbox i have all i have
i have x no apparently not
but i got cam pass as well and that's
what i'm looking forward to is like i
can jump on tunic i'll go on steam and
i'll get have a nice death and then i'm
gonna go turn around and play elden ring
and go through all these different
things it's like i'm at lucky at a point
but if somebody does turn and say should
i get an xbox or should i get a
playstation well who's it for is it
somebody that has disposable income and
you like single player adventure games
do you want to see this piece
okay that's probably a good thing do you
have a kid you want to give them game
pass there is not probably going to be
anything better for value for that kid
and they get to experience a bunch of
stuff and theoretically with the
acquisitions it's going to last for a
while like all access for xbox
that is a stupid deal that's how i
bought my xbox series x
i have a serious x down there that's
like 35 bucks a month and i'm like
oh you did all access yeah right i was
like that's right there was no i was
going to get a game pass ultimate anyway
just part of the package
and i'm paying it off faster just but i
was like there's no reason it's zero
it's zero interest hard to go wrong so
honestly it's like you pay the same
strict price you're right there's no
interest at all on that so it's like
honestly when it came to the playstation
plus prices from the rumors i saw was
gonna be like sixty dollars for three
months or whatever i was like all right
that looks terrifying please don't do it
4chan i know it was a bad leak and the
prices didn't even match up and it was
fine but when it when it finally dropped
i was like all right this seems
reasonable it's a different model and i
think at this point
since this got way off topic for a
minute i was trying to reel it back in
i do think however you choose to play
your games at this point you have a lot
of options and
these companies are trying to build in
value
and it's actually it's one of the best
times to be a gamer because wherever you
are it does seem like you're going to
have access to a lot of things if you
feel like getting into that subscription
model
no matter which platform because now
they all seem to have a subscription
model so
that was me trying to
culminate this thing it was a really
good uh round table assessment i got to
say that was pretty damn good i was
listening for a while that's what
happens when you don't talk about it
can get loud too and crossfire is
crossfire is built on
shows are like that it's just like that
so i apologize that's the only way i've
uh ever come up through the the uh
podcast
it
i know where it's coming from
me and much are from that so it's what
it is
one who just wants to like bash my voice
in between a couple of others so i'm
just going to listen to you yeah you
know and it's funny you know you're 100
right i just so funny coming from like
cox where we where we just our shows
stem from and from the early days too
going way back right
i mean back in the day you go way back i
mean there was
i'm with e there was almost no point
where you could get like it was just
like five people six people talking over
each other right yeah and i remember
going back listening to the play through
and i was like oh now i heard what that
guy said you know what i mean it was
like oh okay now they're all pieced
together so
yeah
mike
yeah it's uh it's a fun time to be a
gamer it's fun time to be a destiny
gamer and also with elven ring and
horizon and star field which could be a
game changer of rpgs i mean what we keep
hearing about that sounds amazing i'm
gonna want to check it out so i'm just
excited for all of the stuff that we've
got and destiny is at a point where it's
playing nice that we can actually touch
these other games and be like cool so
i'm pretty excited about that but i
think that is probably a good place to
wrap it up because this went longer than
expected for everybody who's tired
um
but before we go uh if you guys
you now know mooch's voice so now it's
your turn to tell him where to find that
voice awesome awesome guys by the way
outstanding panel and i love it honestly
i you know like i always say on on my
show i'll say here too great to get
difference of opinions really i think
that that's
it's one of the most important things
you know what i'm saying and cog mean
you i guess a meek have history that
just goes way way back
you know communities together because
they didn't even want to have the
discussion of disagreeing thank you
thank you cognito because you remember
that too that was right now we did it
right yes and uh he's been a dear friend
ever since i want to say that much too
in the whole ilp crew
um so and you know shout out to give a
quick shout out to king david and lord
sav and also the great lord ready to
jump
ready to tag in i know oh i know he was
i don't want to leave if i was like save
yourself dude
another hour and a half
has like full room to my discord so
whenever we get into this attic just
jumps on crosstalk
he just jumps right in which by the way
and by the way e i don't blame you but i
i i encourage attic that was jumping on
crossfire but no i hear you um so shout
out to everybody here great to meet
travis too always seen travis on twitter
never got a chance to talk to him
awesome awesome guy uh appreciate all
his honest opinions and his reviews uh
and abontis just uh the man i always
call just he's the destiny guy and i
know there's a lot of that he goes
there's a lot of destiny guys out there
mooch i'm like yeah but you're my
destiny guy so shout out to we bought
this uh just a great overall show uh you
guys can find me over at mooch tv
and i kind of rebranded it a bit because
i wanted people to be able to find where
i am so it's mooch tv drop the o's for
zeros it's m zero zero ch tv right well
somebody 15 years ago did mooch tv it's
not my fault you know what i mean i'm
just trying to keep up with the times so
naturally right and by the way i should
applaud that i should applaud that much
by the way so anyways it's much mooch tv
everywhere that's twitter youtube and
twitch and uh guys yeah we go live
tomorrow 7 p.m eastern time if you do
want to hear a tad of yelling and a tad
of loud
voices noises loud noises what are we
screaming so uh shout out to everybody
that was here in the chat too an
outstanding chat you have here guys by
the way everybody's just welcoming very
talkative uh made me feel right at home
for my first time on the show so i just
want to say shout out to the chat and uh
yeah guys please go over check me out on
all those uh
great social media spaces and we'll see
you guys hopefully tomorrow crossfire
7pm eastern time nice no doubt the mulch
in the building always good talking
[ __ ] thank you guys you gonna get a
great energetic show with which i'm
telling you right now
thoroughly if this man had been playing
destiny for the past like
four or five weeks yes would have been a
different show
100
i'll tone the yelling down if you guys
will help me back on after i play a
little whiskey
i'll turn it down i can do that i can do
that i do know how to do it in season 19
once we know all this pvp stuff we'll
get you back and we can have the pvp
debate 2.0 that sounds phenomenal
absolutely phenomenal to the chat
everybody pulling up having a good time
had a lot of fun laughs dude so yeah
what is all it was a show today for sure
but yeah that's all i got man and uh
you trash looking to find people find
both of you subscribers what about you
man
well yeah you can read my articles
previews and reviews on ign.com small
little website we're putting together
yes
this
yeah this uh week i i did a preview for
a um an interesting game made by an
indie studio called stitch heads called
super fuse it's kind of like a diablo
inspired kind of arpg um that's
superhero comic book themed it's it's
very interesting um you can read that
online if you want i'm also on a show on
sunday mornings called bitcast where we
talk about industry stuff
um we are also
joined by a lawyer
named richard hogue uh a industry vet
named uh ainsley bowden and a rapidly
decaying corpse uh that mostly just uh
lingers in the corner of the room and uh
yeah so
i forget his name but he's always there
um and uh yeah you can you can watch
that on sunday mornings at uh 7 a.m or 8
a.m pacific
other than that though it's been awesome
as always love hanging out with my
destiny fam and uh follow me on twitter
at ty guy travis if you hate yourself
yeah that's all i've got
no doubt
ah well cog of course always a pleasure
to get a chance to catch up with you
twice this week though let's go check
out defining dude ultimate that was a
great
you guys got to see me in non-host form
so i got to i got to talk a little more
uh i let him talk y'all yeah he is like
he let me he opened open the floodgates
a little bit but honestly it's like when
we start talking about which queen
there's there's a lot of good to like
but
wait to the end we still you know we
save our
save our moment where we still got to
make sure the game still needs a little
fixing around the edges
um so definitely check out the finding
the ultimate last hand media of course
please go hit the f5 button and put a
bot on it for travis's reviews blow up
those numbers please please blow it out
i want to see those get really high and
please go check out mooch
thank you heated debates crossfire
always very entertaining so if you enjoy
style spicy chats will be coming
tomorrow night so please go check out
mooch and the crossfire podcast always a
friend group in there good mix of people
you've got to always every time i check
and you're going to listen thank you
thank you thank you guys so much really
truly means a lot and thank you for that
i got to tell you i'm humbled for being
on the show man this is just this is a
great show you guys put together
we don't even glaze over the fact we got
the camera debut like they're like we
got boobs
like yeah
so now salute to you brother like i know
that's such a big deal you know the type
of community is but it's just it's so
cool to be able to to put the man to the
face to the man and 100 expressive you
see
that personality coming out of you out
here
he created himself a drink and he's just
sitting back watching travis go back
okay
i love the way travis discusses things
though i gotta have him on crossfire
this man better have a crowd
for crossfire yeah
so guess what yeah travis i followed you
immediately on twitter
i am getting you a crossfire doesn't
have to be tomorrow we'll work a day out
like the same way you bought this then
he was very patient with me and by the
way shout out to cognito for saying with
the camera absolutely we've been doing
twitch.tv we've been doing cam for about
a month and a half two months now oh
cool so you know and but i gotta give
the props to ibontes he really says the
same thing he says mooch you can come on
in any way you want to but really this
is how we do the show and i said listen
he said to me watching come on weeks ago
i didn't have it set up yet i said
listen yeah
i said if you can wait for me i'm gonna
do your show right so absolutely thank
you
for his patience as well outstanding
show and uh you know like i said this
may not be the typical last word but man
i had a good time on tonight's show and
i'm talking about even the destiny stuff
was just phenomenal thank you guys for
bringing me up to speed as well no doubt
honestly it's a good one for somebody to
hear
as you said who may have been lapsed
hasn't played for a while you know their
addiction wore off for a little while
they got to see if they want to pick it
back up that's right um but yeah for me
it's literally a bonus everywhere twitch
twitter youtube thank you guys for
hanging streams have been a lot of elden
ring um and then destiny content of
course on the channel but it was an
absolute pleasure shout out to chat you
guys have been amazing uh all of the
super chats thank you for coming in gk
bows with the membership and a lot of
super chats tonight thank you very much
for all of the wonderful generosity um
but it's been a pleasure but we are
going to wrap this one up here so
episode number 191
wrap it up march 31st finally kicking
off spring with a spicy spicy episode
thank you guys very much all of you for
being here and for this episode it has
been